Hey, so I'm here with the go off queen of LinkedIn. It's got a great sub stack. There's a lot of problems affecting mental health care, you know, from structure to service delivery, a ton of things. But today is a good day because it'll all be over. You know, we're going to talk for just a little bit. And all of the problems will we're going to figure out the solution to all of those things so that they will no longer be affecting you and probably will be solved by the time you're listening to this podcast so just an fyi we're really excited um can you tell me a little bit about your work because i don't know a ton about your history like i've read your writing and i like it um but i don't know a ton about how you got there there maybe i missed a bio somewhere on the sub stack but yeah no worries oh thanks for that introduction go off queen i'm gonna use that i'm taking that well i just like i don't know linkedin like used to be it just it's like people trying to be funny and do a meme but also be an hr department like at the same time and so it's just like the worst types of posts usually like the most broad stuff
嘿，我和LinkedIn上的“吐槽女王”在一起。她有一个很棒的Substack专栏。心理健康护理领域存在很多问题，你知道的，从结构到服务交付，方方面面。但今天是个好日子，因为这一切都将结束。我们要聊一会儿，然后我们会找出所有这些问题的解决方案，这样它们就不会再困扰你了，而且等你听到这期播客时，这些问题可能都已经解决了，所以先给你透个底，我们真的很兴奋。嗯，你能跟我聊聊你的工作吗？因为我对你的经历了解不多，我读过你的文章，我很喜欢，但我不太清楚你是怎么走到这一步的，也许我在Substack上漏掉了你的简介，不过没关系。哦，谢谢你的介绍，“吐槽女王”，我要用这个称呼，我收下了。我只是觉得，我不知道，LinkedIn以前不是这样的，现在就像是人们试图表现得幽默、玩梗，但同时又想扮演人力资源部门的角色，所以通常都是最糟糕的那种帖子，内容非常空泛。
stuffiness too yeah because you know which i get you're looking for a job or you need to show that you're professional or something. But I just love sharing stuff that is like kind of subversive and against that or just weird because it's like, yeah, I don't know. I don't really need over it. I'm kind of over trying to be super professional and in HR. Like, that's kind of my whole angle. So but you asked about my background. So my background is as an LMHC. I went to a K-Cred accredited program in Southern Maine, where I'm from, did all the hours, all the licensure, got fully licensed. I really mostly worked in community clinics. So that outpatient, you know, therapeutic work was my jam, thought I
也很沉闷，是的，因为我知道，你是在找工作，或者你需要展示你的专业性之类的。但我就是喜欢分享那些有点颠覆性、反主流或者只是很奇怪的内容，因为，是的，我不知道。我真的不想再那样了。我已经厌倦了试图表现得超级专业和像个HR。这就是我的整个切入点。你问到了我的背景，我的背景是一名持证心理健康咨询师（LMHC）。我在家乡缅因州南部参加了一个获得K-Cred认证的项目，完成了所有的实习时长，完成了所有的执照要求，并获得了完全执照。我主要是在社区诊所工作。所以那种门诊的、你知道的，治疗工作是我的强项，我以为我
would do that my entire life. Like I really became a therapist very young, I think I was 25 when I was conditionally licensed and then, you know, a little bit older, fully licensed. And that's a really hard, you know, road hoe, as a lot of people know, when they're getting into this profession, very young. And so what year was that? Like what's going on? That was, I graduated in 2012 and I left clinical practice by 2018. What was your training in or what did you, were you having any observations about the field as you were coming into it at that time? Yeah, I think I was just trying to
这辈子都会做这个。我真的很年轻就成了治疗师，我想我25岁时获得了有条件执照，然后，你知道的，年纪大一点后获得了完全执照。正如许多人所知，在很年轻的时候进入这个行业，这是一条非常艰难的路。那是哪一年？发生了什么？那是2012年毕业的，我在2018年离开了临床实践。你当时接受的是什么培训，或者你在进入这个领域时对它有什么观察吗？是的，我想我当时只是在尝试
survive it, trying to figure out what it meant to be a good clinically sound ethical therapist. At that time, I was only had access really to being trained in like cognitive behavioral therapy, some acceptance and commitment, which I enjoyed motivational interviewing. And, you know, I could, I didn't even have access to being trained though in like DBT or any sort of EMDR or trauma informed that was very specialized at that time. Only like a few clinicians in each sort of practice or clinic even could do that work. So that was, we can get into any, anywhere we want to go in this conversation. That was really limiting too. You know, I just, I only had access to like a pretty narrow scope of like the evidence based, you know, treatments and seeing the people I was seeing, it was like, well, this
生存下去，试图弄清楚成为一名临床上稳健、合乎道德的治疗师意味着什么。那时，我真正能接触到的培训只有认知行为疗法（CBT）、一些接纳承诺疗法（ACT），我喜欢动机访谈。而且，你知道，我甚至没有机会接受像DBT（辩证行为疗法）或任何形式的EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）或创伤知情护理的培训，那在当时是非常专业的。每个实践或诊所里只有少数临床医生能做那种工作。所以那真的很受限。你知道，我只能接触到非常狭窄的循证治疗范围，看着我接待的那些人，我觉得，嗯，这
is only going to work like some of the time, you know, I could kind of tell very quickly that I was seeing such a broad scope of folks that I didn't really know how to help, you know, and I was able to acknowledge that. But that's sort of the moral injury of it, too, you know, that you're just expected to treat all these people without really given the tools and the skills and the supervision and the support to actually navigate that successfully. So that was just one piece of why I kind of transitioned out of direct clinical practice. Yeah, I remember that feeling of just terror when you're like, oh, I don't know. I don't know how to conceptualize this.
只能在某些时候起作用，你知道，我很快就能看出我接待的群体范围太广了，我真的不知道该如何帮助他们，你知道，我能够承认这一点。但这也是其中的道德伤害，你知道，你只是被期望去治疗所有这些人，却没有被给予真正的工具、技能、督导和支持来成功地应对这一切。所以这只是我离开直接临床实践的部分原因。是的，我记得那种恐惧感，当你觉得，哦，我不知道。我不知道该如何概念化这个。
I haven't heard this. And then you go and you read and you take the CE and you keep like I just always, but the right out of school because it doesn't prepare you. School doesn't prepare you to be a therapist. You know, it takes takes a lot of other stuff. It does. And, you know, it takes the right environment, too, for years and years, I think, after school, you know. Because I hear, I consult, you know, with clinicians all the time.
我没听说过这个。然后你去阅读，去参加继续教育（CE），你一直……我总是这样，但刚出校门时，学校并没有为你做好准备。学校并没有让你准备好成为一名治疗师。你知道，这需要很多其他的东西。确实。而且，我认为在学校毕业后的很多年里，也需要合适的环境。因为我经常与临床医生进行咨询。
And, you know, they're mostly clinicians who are unhappy with where they are or they're feeling burnt out. Even graduate students sometimes will reach out and just want to be like, okay, so, like, what's really going to happen for me when I get up there, when I'm, you know, not protected anymore, insulated, you know, by the academic world. And so we have frank conversations, but, you know, I don't deter, I try not to deter people, you know, from their passion because nobody could have deterred me from becoming a professional counselor. I was that. So that's not my angle, but it is to speak like openly and authentically about what we've all sort of experienced, or at least for myself. And there's generally, you know, one of the themes is that there is not a lot of high quality supervision. There is really no mentorship opportunities for folks. And it's so expensive.
而且，你知道，他们大多是对现状不满或感到精疲力竭的临床医生。甚至研究生有时也会联系我，只是想问，好吧，那么，当我走上岗位，当我不再受到学术界的保护和隔离时，我到底会经历什么？所以我们进行了坦诚的对话，但是，你知道，我不会劝阻，我尽量不去劝阻人们追求他们的热情，因为没有人能劝阻我成为一名专业咨询师。我就是那样的人。所以这不是我的切入点，但我的目的是公开、真实地谈论我们大家都经历过的事情，或者至少是我自己的经历。通常，你知道，其中一个主题是缺乏高质量的督导。人们真的没有导师机会。而且这太贵了。
And it's so costly. The people who can do the trauma therapy. I mean, my license is as a social worker, so there's kind of different humps that you have to get over and a little bit different of a struggle than at LMHC and ALC and some of the different counseling programs. But it's like, you already have to go to school. You already have to pay all this to go to school. Then you're told that you can't say you do this, even though it's pretty intuitive until you have this training.
而且成本太高了。那些能做创伤治疗的人。我的执照是社会工作者，所以你需要跨越不同的障碍，这与LMHC和ALC以及一些不同的咨询项目所面临的挣扎略有不同。但就像是，你已经必须去上学了。你已经必须支付所有这些学费去上学。然后你被告知，即使这很直观，但在你接受这种培训之前，你不能说你会做这个。
The piece of paper says that and you've got to go out and get supervision which is just expensive to afford at all but then if somebody actually has like a lot of clinical practice skills well they can already make two three hundred dollars an hour seeing patients so what through you to see them for supervision is a pretty big cost proposition and it's just like everyone keeps saying like mental health crisis let's like smooth licensure out and across states or something. And it's like, okay, that's fine. But just to be able to pay, you know, $15,000 for a career where you're maybe going to make 30, 35, like when you're first coming out, I mean, how do you, how do you change that, you know, reality without there being more support there than there is. Absolutely. It's a really, it's just one more piece of what makes, you know, a lot of these
那张纸上是这么写的，你必须出去找督导，这本身就很昂贵，根本负担不起。但如果某人真的拥有很多临床实践技能，他们已经可以每小时赚两三百美元看病人了，所以让他们花钱找你做督导是一个相当大的成本命题。每个人都在说，心理健康危机，让我们简化跨州的执照认证之类的。这很好。但仅仅是为了支付1.5万美元的费用，去从事一份刚入行时可能只能赚3万、3.5万美元的职业，我的意思是，如果没有比现在更多的支持，你怎么能改变那种现实呢？绝对是这样。这只是让很多这些
helping professions kind of untenable. Like we don't make a lot of money to begin with and to have to come out of your own pocket to just try and get better at your craft or just try and feel like you're doing the best you can by your patients and developing your own clinical skills. It feels really impossible, you know, especially for folks who are not well resourced, you know, like a lot of the people who are able to survive this industry are folks who have a certain level of privilege in society, right? Like there's a lot of, there's a lot of white women in therapy, right? Overwhelmingly female, you know, dominated profession. And, you know, I see that as people with just enough
助人职业变得难以维持的又一个因素。我们本来就赚不到多少钱，还要自掏腰包去提升自己的手艺，或者只是为了感觉自己在尽力对待病人并发展自己的临床技能。这感觉真的很不可能，你知道，特别是对于那些资源不足的人来说，你知道，在这个行业中能够生存下来的人，很多都是在社会中拥有一定特权的人，对吧？治疗行业里有很多白人女性，对吧？这是一个绝大多数由女性主导的职业。而且，你知道，我把这看作是那些拥有足够
privilege to get themselves into, right, graduate school, to have the loans, to, you know, do that trajectory, but not enough privilege, it seems to actually create a lot of change from, you know, within these structures and these systemic failures that we're seeing everywhere. So it's a really sort of enclosed space that seems forever shrinking in terms of finding safe places for clinicians to be able to show up, be themselves, do the work, not be inundated with, you know, high volume caseloads and the whole thing. It's just it seems wildly untenable. And I've been out of clinical practice since, like I said, 2018. And I'm paying attention, you know, I'm like sort of this observer that cares very deeply and is paying attention. And it seems to only have gotten worse in a lot of ways.
特权进入研究生院、背负贷款、走上那条职业轨迹的人，但似乎并没有足够的特权在这些结构和我们随处可见的系统性失败中真正创造出很多改变。所以这是一个非常封闭的空间，在寻找让临床医生能够出现、做自己、完成工作、不被高负荷病例淹没的安全场所方面，它似乎永远在萎缩。这看起来极其难以维持。正如我所说，我从2018年起就离开了临床实践。我一直在关注，我就像是一个非常关心并一直在观察的人。而且在很多方面，情况似乎只会变得更糟。
And I think private practice route, the entrepreneurial route seems to be sort of the one way, right? To find, to survive. And I think that's great. I will always, always support, you know, people's autonomy to do what they need to do to get by and work in a way, you know, that makes them feel safe and loved and supported. But, and, you know, and that's not fixed. That's actually not a solution to these systemic issues that just were, we continue to bump up against time and time again. Well, and that was one of the things that I was interested in, because this has been on the books
我认为私人执业路线，即创业路线，似乎是生存下去的唯一途径。我认为这很好。我将永远、永远支持人们为了生存而做他们需要做的事情，并以一种让他们感到安全、被爱和被支持的方式工作。但是，你知道，这并没有解决问题。这实际上并不是解决我们一次又一次碰壁的这些系统性问题的方案。嗯，这也是我感兴趣的事情之一，因为这已经在书面上存在了
forever. So I would see a LinkedIn post, I'd be like, oh, I want to ask a question about that. And then I would forget about it. And then I'd see another thing and be like, oh, we're going to talk about this. But you're reminding me of one of the things that you posted a long time ago, which is the structure of these practices and the ethics of that. And you're reminding me of one of the things that you posted a long time ago, which is the structure of these practices and the ethics of that. And you're saying like, you know, I'm open to there being like another alternative where people aren't exploited, but I don't see that. There's either these practices that take this huge percentage of your income or you're just kind of or you do your time. You get a lot of street cred. Now you're well known and you have a referral base and you can charge whatever you want and don't have to take insurance.
很久了。所以我看到一个LinkedIn帖子，我会想，哦，我想问个问题。然后我就忘了。然后我又看到另一件事，心想，哦，我们要谈谈这个。但你让我想起了你很久以前发布的一件事，那就是这些诊所的结构及其背后的伦理。你让我想起了你很久以前发布的一件事，那就是这些诊所的结构及其背后的伦理。你说，你知道，我愿意接受有另一种选择，让人们不被剥削，但我没看到。要么是这些拿走你收入很大一部分的诊所，要么就是你熬时间。你积累了很多声誉，现在你出名了，有了转诊基础，你可以收取任何你想收的费用，而不必接受保险。
But you're on your own. So like, how do you, you you know and then there's some group practices where people split the cost of a waiting room essentially or you know the water bottle you know machine getting refilled but that it's everybody's kind of they're doing their own thing and to talk about like what the future could look like because like yeah i wouldn't advocate for somebody unless they just love it or that's their career path to stay in the hospital and start off making 30 and then top out maybe making 50,000 if they really like you and you do your time. But then also we have to have bigger practices. Like it's not like we can just have everybody in private practice, you know, doing their thing.
但你得靠自己。所以，你怎么……你知道，还有一些团体诊所，人们基本上分摊候诊室的费用，或者你知道，饮水机换水的费用，但每个人都在做自己的事情。谈谈未来可能是什么样子，因为，是的，除非某人热爱这份工作，或者这是他们的职业道路，否则我不会建议某人留在医院，起薪3万，如果他们真的很喜欢你，你熬了时间，顶薪可能也就5万。但我们也必须有更大的诊所。并不是说我们每个人都能在私人执业中做自己的事情。
So what does that look like? And I wonder when you do consulting, what are structures that you see as helpful pathways going forward to have a more equitable mental health? It's hard. It's really hard. I don't know that the solutions really exist yet. And what I'm interested in is people who want to have those conversations, who are actually say, like, these are the things that aren't working. How can we rethink that? How can we do this differently? You know, but there's a lot of built by design oppression, right? Like, what can we really do to change reimbursement rates if, you know, insurers and corporations are not willing to understand how that trickles down and affects our ability to make a living or just to stay in these professions at all, right? There's very little it feels like we can do as individuals or even as a united collective to really work against such an enormous power
那么那会是什么样子呢？我想知道当你做咨询时，你认为哪些结构是未来实现更公平的心理健康服务的有效途径？这很难。真的很难。我不知道解决方案是否真的存在。我感兴趣的是那些想要进行这些对话的人，他们实际上说，这些是行不通的事情。我们如何重新思考？我们如何以不同的方式做到这一点？你知道，但有很多“设计好的压迫”，对吧？如果保险公司和企业不愿意理解这如何层层传导并影响我们维持生计或留在这些行业的能力，我们真的能做些什么来改变报销率呢？作为个人，甚至作为一个团结的集体，我们能做的似乎很少，无法真正对抗这种巨大的权力
differential that really does sort of dictate our ability to survive. And then, you know, you mentioned the other path, which is the cash pay route. That's viable for a lot of people. It works for a lot of people. I think when I spend a lot of time with that, I think ethics come in there. Gosh, people might be going broke just for the opportunity to spend an hour a week with me. And I know that the people who really need support are never going to be able to afford these costs. And therapists charge what they deserve. You know, that's not a, we really sort of demonize, I think, a lot of these rates that we see from therapists who are charging out of pocket. And I think that's
差异，而这种差异确实在某种程度上决定了我们的生存能力。然后，你提到了另一条路，即现金支付路线。这对很多人来说是可行的。它对很多人有效。我想当我花很多时间思考这个问题时，我认为伦理问题就出现了。天哪，人们可能仅仅为了每周花一小时和我在一起就破产了。我知道那些真正需要支持的人永远负担不起这些费用。治疗师收取他们应得的费用。你知道，这不是……我们确实在某种程度上妖魔化了我们从那些自费的治疗师那里看到的很多费率。我认为这是
misguided as well. Therapists are doing what they need to do to survive this industry. And if it doesn't work for them for a million reasons to contract with insurers, then they're choosing, like they're taking back their power and saying, well, it's great and you can pay this or you can't pay this. And a lot of people are paying it and a lot of folks are busy and that's okay. It's not therapist's fault that the system is designed to not pay them, not to create this humanistic work. Which hits them against patients too. So it's not healthy.
也是被误导的。治疗师正在做他们需要做的事情来在这个行业中生存。如果由于种种原因，与保险公司签约对他们行不通，那么他们就是在选择，他们是在收回自己的权力，说，好吧，这很好，你可以付这个钱，或者你付不起。很多人都在付钱，很多人都很忙，这没关系。系统被设计成不支付费用，不创造这种人文主义的工作，这不是治疗师的错。这也会让他们与病人产生对立。所以这不健康。
I mean, patients take away the social worker's greedy or something because they're not aware of how these issues work. Yeah, and it gets very taxing, right? To have to continue to explain to your own clients or patients what's happening here. Like why it has to be this way. Well, this is insurance is very difficult to deal with. Let me talk to you about that. You know, or, or, and then it goes into like even diagnosis and treatment stuff. Like, well, let me explain to
我的意思是，病人会觉得社会工作者贪婪之类的，因为他们不知道这些问题是如何运作的。是的，这变得非常繁重，对吧？不得不继续向你自己的客户或病人解释这里发生了什么。比如为什么必须这样。嗯，保险公司很难打交道。让我跟你谈谈那个。你知道，或者，或者，然后它会深入到诊断和治疗方面。比如，嗯，让我解释一下
you why I have to give you a diagnosis in order for us to work together because yeah insurance you know so i think that's really exhausting and like i think about potentially if ever to go back to clinical practice i get exhausted just thinking about having to educate you know person after person it's not people's fault that they don't know these things right but there's just this whole education piece to understand. The system's like the way that it works and the way that it makes money is based on it being too hard for you to know what your rights are to navigate any of it. That is so overwhelming. You know, like people are like, well, it's the patient's responsibility to know their plan or
为什么我必须给你一个诊断，我们才能一起工作，因为是的，保险公司，你知道。所以我认为这真的很让人精疲力竭，而且我想，如果有一天要回到临床实践，光是想到要教育一个又一个人，我就感到精疲力竭。这不是人们的错，他们不知道这些事情，对吧？但要理解这一点，确实有一个完整的教育过程。这个系统的运作方式以及它赚钱的方式，是基于让你太难知道你的权利是什么，从而无法驾驭这一切。这太让人不知所措了。你知道，人们会说，嗯，了解自己的计划是病人的责任，或者
whatever. It's like, I don't know 300 pages of my insurance plan and like when it pays for therapy where and now there's like you know these more obfuscatory like secret networks where they're like oh you're in network with you know this insurance company but you're not in the double special network where you actually get money for being in the it's like no you're in the network or you're not like that's not you don't know what network means like um you know there's like these three tiers now um like when my wife when we had our baby like we went to the hospital no complications the first one you know just like in and out and we get a bill in the mail that's like you owe sixty thousand dollars but good news right off with insurance they paid fifty nine thousand you know ninety or whatever so only thirty dollars is what you owe
什么的。这就像，我不知道我保险计划的300页内容，也不知道它在哪里支付治疗费用。现在还有这些更令人困惑的“秘密网络”，他们说，哦，你在这个保险公司的网络内，但你不在那个双重特殊网络内，你实际上无法因为在里面而获得报销。这就像，不，你要么在网络内，要么不在。你不知道“网络”是什么意思。你知道，现在有这三个层级。比如我妻子生孩子的时候，我们去了医院，没有并发症，第一个，你知道，就是进进出出，然后我们收到一张账单，上面写着你欠6万美元，但好消息是，保险公司支付了5.9万美元，或者其他什么，所以你只需要付30美元。
and it's like maybe like like no money changed hands there like people look at this bill because it's a bill and the whole system is like well here's the fake rate that we say the insurance pays but actually they don't get it but then if you didn't have insurance then this is the price like it's the whole point is to make those things so murky and untransparent that you just see a big number it gets scared you're like oh i'm glad i have insurance i would have been on the hook sixty thousand dollars i mean blue Cross didn't pay anything to Grandview. You know, there was just part of like maybe, you know, $200 changed hands there or something for that, for that hour of time.
这就像，也许……没有钱在那里易手。人们看着这张账单，因为它是一张账单，整个系统就像是，好吧，这是我们说的保险支付的虚假费率，但实际上他们并没有得到它。但如果你没有保险，那么这就是价格。重点就是让这些事情变得如此模糊和不透明，以至于你只看到一个巨大的数字，感到害怕，你会想，哦，我很高兴我有保险，否则我就要承担6万美元的债务了。我的意思是，蓝十字保险公司并没有给Grandview支付任何费用。你知道，那里面可能只有200美元易手了，或者其他什么，为了那一小时的时间。
Yeah. So when people are looking at these prices and things like they don't understand, I mean, they don't understand how any of this works by design, I think. Yeah. No, you highlight some really important, you know, flaws in the system. And like, a lot of these numbers are completely arbitrary, right? It's a warfare, right? Between hospital systems particular and what insurers are not willing to do, right? And we've been in this race for three or four decades now. It's inflating prices on one end and pretending that there's deep
是的。所以当人们看着这些价格和事情时，他们不明白，我的意思是，我认为他们根本不明白这一切是如何设计的。是的。不，你强调了一些系统中非常重要的缺陷。而且，很多这些数字完全是武断的，对吧？这是一场战争，对吧？在医院系统和保险公司之间，他们不愿意做什么，对吧？我们已经在这场竞赛中跑了三四十年了。它在一端推高价格，在另一端假装通过这些第三方仲裁者获得深度的
discounts and some sort of benefit from having these third party arbitrators on the other end. And it's this this battle and this dance and patients and providers are lost and not heard in any of it. So yeah, you see these fake numbers of my father in law has some health issues. And he actually had like a VAD device implanted for his heart. And so he's had a lot of hospital stuff going on. And so he has like a, not to get too specific, but he has like a permanent sort of open wound that he'll have to take care of for the rest of his life. And his coverage now says, well, we don't cover like supplies for that anymore. That's not part of your policy coverage, even though it's absolutely medically necessary, he will require that for the rest of his life. But insurers just get to say, no,
折扣和某种利益。这是一场战斗，一场舞蹈，而病人和提供者在其中迷失了，没有被倾听。所以是的，你看到了这些虚假的数字。我岳父有一些健康问题。他实际上植入了一个VAD设备来辅助心脏。所以他有很多医院的事情要处理。所以他有一个，不想说得太具体，但他有一个永久性的开放性伤口，他余生都必须照顾它。而他的保险现在说，嗯，我们不再承保那样的用品了。那不是你保单承保范围的一部分，尽管它绝对是医疗必需的，他余生都需要它。但保险公司就是可以说，不，
we don't do that anymore. You know, after they give you the port or whatever, too, you know? Yeah. Right. I mean, that's what these permanent surgeries, we're seeing that. And I mean, by the way, to anybody who, you know, doesn't know a ton about this, no one else in the world does this. There's no other first world country that looks two percent like our system like it is it is one of the weirdest most backwards things that we just continue to layer more and more weird on instead of kind of going back to the drawing board and saying like this doesn't work it's going to fall apart let's go ahead and take it apart and figure out something sustainable now i mean we just keep propping up this lumbering beast of a mess and i
我们不再那样做了。你知道，在他们给你装上接口或其他什么之后，也是这样，对吧？是的。没错。我的意思是，这就是这些永久性手术，我们正在看到这种情况。而且，顺便说一句，对于任何不知道这一点的人来说，世界上没有其他人这样做。没有其他第一世界国家看起来像我们的系统，哪怕只有百分之二。这是最奇怪、最倒退的事情之一，我们只是不断地在上面叠加更多奇怪的东西，而不是回到绘图板上说，这行不通，它会分崩离析，让我们把它拆开，找出一些可持续的东西。我的意思是，我们只是不断地支撑着这个笨重的烂摊子，我
mean we're in sure like you know like a lot of times i think the perception is that the therapist doesn't take insurance because they're like greedy or something but i mean there's not like an hour of therapy it's not an hour of my time you know it's 30 minutes charting it's following up with everyone on your release of information sheet it's the i mean when i got trained in brain spotting i had two thousand dollars in that cost me three thousand dollars to get trained in emdr i'm thinking about in four thousand close to five thousand dollars in emotional transformation therapy training now with the devices and the equipment and the travels have probably got about there so i mean to really keep pace with this
意思是，我们当然……你知道，很多时候我认为人们的看法是，治疗师不接受保险是因为他们贪婪之类的，但我的意思是，这不是一小时的治疗，这不是我的一小时时间，你知道，这是30分钟的记录，是跟进你知情同意书上的每个人，是……我的意思是，当我接受脑点疗法（Brainspotting）培训时，我花了2000美元，那花了我3000美元接受EMDR培训，我正在考虑四千，接近五千美元的情绪转化疗法（ETT）培训，现在加上设备和差旅，可能已经差不多了。所以，我的意思是，要真正跟上这个
industry that's changing pretty quickly and moving away from just cognitive and behavioral therapies into more brain-based stuff it's very expensive it's like another master's degree yeah that's that's what's built into it like if i don't have the money to go to those trainings i can't do that next year you know and and then how am i different from the therapists who you're coming to see me after it didn't work you know we're tap like the, the end stop for every complex trauma treatment resistant. I've been in therapy. I've tried everything. I mean, do I want to have the cutting edge tools out there and be able to refer you to them, even if it's not through us. So, you know, all that. It becomes increasingly, you know, in an industry where only those who are particularly well
发展迅速、正在从单纯的认知和行为疗法转向更多基于大脑的疗法的行业，这非常昂贵。这就像另一个硕士学位。是的，这就是内置在里面的东西。如果我没有钱去参加那些培训，明年我就做不到，你知道。然后我和那些你在治疗失败后来看我的治疗师有什么不同？你知道，我们是每一个复杂创伤、治疗抵抗者的最后防线。我接受过治疗。我尝试过一切。我的意思是，我是否想拥有最前沿的工具，并能够把你转介给它们，即使不是通过我们？所以，你知道，所有这些。它变得越来越……在一个只有那些特别有资源的人才能……
resourced or, or you're right, figure out how to do, you know, very specific industry where only those who are particularly well resourced or, right, figure out how to do, you know, very specific treatments, these are the only folks who really, I think, survive. It just, it just gets so untenable. You know, another thing is, you know, the, the high, high prevalence of 1099 contracts and, you know, treating sort of the therapy profession seems more and more to be treated like, sort of like this niche, almost like side hustle, you know, this industry that's not really respected, everyone wants to talk about it, everyone wants to talk about mental health, and how important treatment is. But when push comes to shove, so many of these companies and, you know, private practice is its own sort of outlier, I think, compared to like what's happening with larger organizations. And
或者，你是对的，弄清楚如何做……非常具体的行业，只有那些特别有资源的人，或者，对，弄清楚如何做……非常具体的治疗，这些才是唯一真正生存下来的人。这变得太难以维持了。你知道，另一件事是，1099合同的高流行率，你知道，把治疗职业越来越像是一种利基市场，几乎像是一种副业，你知道，这个行业并没有真正受到尊重，每个人都想谈论它，每个人都想谈论心理健康，以及治疗有多重要。但当真正需要的时候，这么多公司，而且私人执业本身就是一种离群值，我认为，相比于大型组织正在发生的事情。而且
when you work in community mental health and it's sort of like a safe haven for folks. And I love that. And often what I, what I think about is how can we pull what works for so many therapists in private practice back into these other environments that clearly are not taking any of these ideas, messages, principles into consideration when you're trying to take what makes the private practice guy lean and mean and competitive and then pull that institute pull that individual knowledge into an institution and the two things are one just like size like when you have a really big hospital when you have a really big anything change kind of becomes the enemy no matter how many courses you say we want to improve and innovate and please bring your suggestions and new ideas up front like you don't you can't really believe that. And you get this kind of like insecurity at the end of the, like USSR imploding of like, well, that's a very good point that you bring up, except like, we cannot be wrong. And, you know, like I just had those interactions in the hospital where it was like, if you're
当你在社区心理健康中心工作时，它就像是人们的避风港。我喜欢这一点。我经常想到的是，我们如何将对许多私人执业治疗师有效的东西带回到这些其他环境中，这些环境显然在试图采取让私人执业者精干、高效且具有竞争力的东西，然后将这种个人知识引入机构时，根本没有考虑任何这些想法、信息、原则。这两件事，一是规模，当你有一个非常大的医院，当你有一个非常大的任何东西时，变革就成了敌人，无论你说多少次“我们想要改进和创新，请提出你的建议和新想法”，你都无法真正相信这一点。你会得到那种苏联解体末期的不安全感，就像，“这是一个很好的观点，除了我们不能犯错。”而且，你知道，我只是在医院里有过那些互动，就像，如果你是对的，我们将不得不回去做大量的工作，我们真的做不到。所以别再说了，尽管我们让你提出好主意。另一件事是资本。我的意思是，这些是追求利润的公司。只要这一点存在，那么我留住一个长期表现很好的人，或者在他们能去和我竞争时就把他们踢出门，然后找一个刚毕业、可能不是很好的治疗师，但我必须雇佣500人，这有什么区别？成本效益对我来说是什么？为什么我要留住这个人，而我可以付给那个人更少的钱？所以较大的地方你
right about this, we're going to have to go back and do so much work that we can't really do that. So just don't say that again, even though we ask you to bring up good ideas. And then the other thing is capital. I mean, that these are profit seeking companies. And as long as that's there, then is there a difference between me keeping somebody for a long time, who's really good, or just kind of kicking them out the door as soon as they can go compete against me and then getting another person who is right out of school and maybe isn't a great therapist, but I got to employ 500 people. So what's the cost benefit for me? Why would I keep this person when I can pay that person less? So the larger places you
可能会得到一个好的治疗师，但如果他们能弄清楚自己的事情，他们就会离开。没错。没错。因为，我认为对于任何行业的任何优秀员工来说，这都是事实，如果你在环境中没有得到很好的对待，优秀的人就会离开，对吧？并相信他们能找到一个更好地支持他们的环境。所以我认为这在很大程度上是我们所看到的。一旦人们建立了一些能力，
may get a good therapist, but if they can figure their thing out, they're going to be on their way out. That's right. That's right. Because, and this is true, I think for any good employee, regardless of what industry you're in, is that if you're not being treated well in your environment, good folks are going to leave, right? And trust that they can find their way to an environment that supports them better. So I think that's largely, you know, what we see. As soon as people build some competency,
他们获得了完全执照，他们意识到他们可以在不被剥削、不被像垃圾一样对待、或者不被那些让他们生病的病例负荷所淹没的情况下做到这一点，你知道，他们会制定计划或意识到他们需要去做一些不同的事情。是的。嗯，大学现在也不同了。我的意思是，很多东西，比如更大的
they get their full licensure, they realize that they can do this without being exploited or without being treated like crap or without being indicted with these caseloads that are making them literally sick, you know, they will make plans or get to that realization where they need to go do something different. Yeah. Well, and the colleges are different now, too. I mean, a ton of the stuff, like the bigger
地方，那些教书的人或者拥有所有奖项的人，他们会说，嗯，我也是一名治疗师。但就像你真的每周在学生咨询中心工作两天，或者类似你正在做的事情。我知道你很有名，你拥有所有这些华丽的博士奖项，但如果你去商场里尝试推销这个，它没有足够的竞争力让任何人购买。因此，就像，嗯，这个人写了书，或者他们拥有所有医学证书，但另一个人精干、高效，通过做这种医院根本做不到的其他事情赚了很多钱。他们将是最后一批接触脑点疗法的人，他们将是最后一批弄清楚
places, the people who teach it or have all the awards or whatever, they'll say, well, I'm a therapist, too. But it's like you're really working at the student counseling center, you know, two days a week or something like what you're doing. And I know that you're famous and you've got all these fancy doctor awards, but if you went and tried to sell this in the strip mall, it's not competitive enough for anyone to buy it. And so because of that, it's like, well, this person wrote the book or they have all the credentials that are medical, but then this other person has leaned in mean and making all this money individually doing this other thing that the hospitals fundamentally can't they're going to be the last to come around to something like brain spotting they're going to be the last to figure
你知道，如何处理EMDR的人，他们从来没有真正弄清楚如何处理那里的研究。他们，你知道，对他们来说，做认知行为疗法和药物总是更容易的。所以你看到像最前沿的私人执业者正在朝着与学术心理学不同的方向发展，这对这个行业来说是一件坏事。我的意思是，我不喜欢这种情况发生，当我指出这一点时，就像，这不应该发生，但它确实发生了，你知道，这么多人从这些项目中出来，被告知，嗯，CBT是黄金标准。它是最好的东西，因为它是最可研究的。是的，绝对。我们在将我们的现实世界学习和对临床实践中有效东西的理解带回到我们所做的事情上做得并不好，你知道，我现在在心理健康和治愈方面重视的东西，并不是我在学术上学到的，你知道，就像我们刚才说的，
out you know what to do with the mdr which they just never really figured out what to do with the research there they're you know it's always going to be easier for them to do cognitive behavioral therapy and drugs and so you see like the cutting edge private practice people moving in a different direction than academic psychology, which is a bad thing for the profession. Like, I don't like that that's happening when I pointed out, like that shouldn't be happening, but it is, you know, so many people come out of these programs being told, well, CBT is the gold standard. It's the best thing ever because it's the most researchable. Yeah, absolutely. We're not doing a very good job bringing back our real world learning and understanding of what works in clinical practice back to things that, you know, I value now in terms of mental health and healing are not things that I learned academically, you know, like, like we were saying,
你知道，CBT是首选。我想它现在仍然是。它相当容易学习。训练人们去做它相当容易。管理它相当容易，虽然不总是这样。它对一些人有效。所以只是……就像五星里给两星，我觉得我们在学校项目中生产的东西在很多环境中就是这样。而且它就是……它就是行不通。而且它特别不适用于临床医生的心理健康。你知道，想象一下，把自己放回研究生院，你当时是多么充满希望，你正在学习所有这些东西，以及从离开研究生院到弄清楚与所有这些不同的人坐在一起到底是什么感觉，以及你感到多么装备不足。而且你缺乏获得培训和导师的机会，因为你赚不到钱。我的意思是，这真的，真的，我认为在治疗师身上造成了太多的内在羞耻感。我写过，那是我经常写的东西，就是
you know, CBT was kind of the go-to. I think it still is. It's fairly easy to learn. It's fairly easy to train people to do. It's fairly easy to administer, not always. And it works for some people. And just so just sort of kind of good, like two stars out of five is what we're getting, I feel like, in a lot of environments with what we're producing, you know, from school programs. And it's just it's just not working. And it's not especially not working for the clinician's mental health. You know, imagine, you know, put yourself back in graduate school and how hopeful you were and all the things you were learning and that curve from leaving graduate school to figuring out what it's really like to be sitting with all these different folks and how ill equipped you really feel. And the lack of access you have because you're not making any money to get yourself trained up to get yourself mentorship. I mean, it's really, really, I think causes so much internalized shame in the therapist. And I write about that's something I write about quite frequently is how
我们的系统崩溃的方式确实产生了这种内在羞耻感，我认为在我们很多人身上，这需要大量的“去学习”和剥离那些层级，才能真正弄清楚，你知道，真的是因为我是一个糟糕的治疗师，还是我真的从来没有得到我需要的东西？现在我知道得更多了，我可以做得更好，你知道，用那个。对于助人行业的人来说，这很多时候是他们重温他们童年创伤的过程，他们还没有完全治愈，或者他们在父母身上扮演的某种角色。我认为当你提出这些问题并试图让人们面对复杂性并承认事情已经崩溃并需要改变时，很多负面反应背后的愤怒是“不，不，不，别那样做。停下。”
the way that our systems are broken does produce this internalized shame, I think in a lot of us, and it takes a lot of unlearning and peeling back those layers to really figure out, you know, is it really that I was a shitty therapist or did I just really never have the things that I needed? And now that I know better, I can do better, you know, with that. Which a lot of times for people in the helping profession is them reliving their childhood trauma that is, they haven't, you know, totally healed yet or some role that they played with a parent. And I think that's a lot of under the negative reactions when you bring these issues up and try and get people to sit with complexity and admit that things are broken and change is the anger of no, no, no, don't do that. Stop.
你为什么要这样做？它源于最初让他们进入这个行业的同一个伤口。你知道，绝对。他们不想承认系统有多崩溃。是的。我只是……我想谢谢你这么说，因为我认为这可能确实触及了我们需要做的事情的根源。因为它让人感到不知所措。我们的客户和病人。我想也许这很天真，但我相信如果我们形成足够多的集体声音，可能会有更多的事情我们可以做来帮助改变这种轨迹，但这确实感觉是一场非常艰难的战斗。而且我理解，你知道，临床医生只是
Why are you why are you doing this? It's it comes from that same wound that got them in the profession in the first place. You know, absolutely. They don't want to admit how broken the system is. Yeah. And I just I guess thanks for saying that, because I think that's really probably gets a bit to the to the root of what I think we need to do. Because it feels overwhelming. our clients and our patients. And I guess maybe it's naive, but I believe that if we form enough collective voices that there might be more things we can do to help change this trajectory, but it does feel like a very uphill battle. And I understand, you know, that clinicians are just
会说，好吧，我只是要挂牌开业，做我自己的事情，埋头苦干，尽我所能，一次只服务一个客户。这没什么错。但我确实要求人们至少时不时地抬起头来，尝试从3万英尺的高度俯瞰。我们如何，你知道，提升这些对话，并在我们如何真正倡导这些系统更好地对待我们所有人并更好地服务我们所有人方面保持一致。是的。而且我认为LPC（持证专业咨询师）和社会工作项目，我希望他们能互相学习一点，因为社会工作项目，就像它只是这种巨大的“人与环境”视角，你在那里学习系统、权力、政治、财富和权力的运作方式以及医疗保健的历史和所有这些事情。但你没有得到很多临床技术，你以后必须去学习，而LPC是
going to say, well, I'm just going to hang my shingle out and do my own thing, keep my head down and do the best I can with one, you know, one, one, one client at a time. And there's nothing wrong with that. But I do ask people to sort of pick up their head, at least from time to time and try and take that 30,000 foot view. And how can we, you know, elevate these conversations and be aligned as a collective and how we're really advocating for these systems to treat us all better and serve us all better. Yeah. And I think like the LPC and the social work programs, I wish would learn a little bit from each other because the social work ones, like it is just this huge person and environment view where you're learning about systems and power and politics and the way that wealth and power functions and the history of healthcare and all these things. But you don't get a lot of the clinical technique you kind of have to pick that up later whereas the lpc is
就像，全是精神病理学，全是这种诊断，但就像你有时无法透过树木看到森林，你知道，在其中一家医院有一个学生案例，全是LPC，他们请了一位社会工作者，那是我的督导之一，进来看看为什么她弄不清楚，她就像……他们试图弄清楚这个有困难的学生的焦虑，他们检查了一遍，所以她把临床心理学家和LPC赶出了房间，问道：“你因为你是非洲裔美国人而所有这些人都是白人而感到不舒服吗？”她说：“是的。”
like it's all psychopathology it's all just like this diagnosis but then it's like you can't see the forest through the trees sometimes you know like there was a case at um one of the hospitals with a student and it was like all lpcs and they asked a social worker that was one of my supervisors to like come in and and see why she couldn't figure out and she was like they were like they were trying to figure out this anxiety with the student who was having difficulty and they went through it and so she like kicked the clinical psychologist and the lpcs out of the room and was like is are you uncomfortable that you're an afric an African-American that all these people are white? She was like, yeah.
她说：“好吧，这就是你们寻找了很久的焦虑来源。”因为，你知道，这个学生不是来自那个社区。她不舒服。但这并没有出现在他们的脑海中，因为就像，“这是哪个F代码，伙计？这是什么诊断？”就像，你几乎……他们知道得太多了，以至于无法透过树木看到森林。绝对。你说得太对了，因为这太真实了。是的，而且我希望那样，我只是想……
She was like, okay, well, there's the source of the anxiety that you guys have been looking for for a long time. Because, you know, this student didn't come from that community. She wasn't comfortable. But it just didn't occur to them because it's like, which F code is this, man? Like, which diagnosis is it? Like, you just almost, they knew too much to kind of see the forest through the trees there. Absolutely. And it's so funny you say that because it's so true yeah and and i wanted it that way i wanted to just
她说，好吧，你们一直在寻找的焦虑根源就在这儿。因为，你知道，这个学生不是来自那个社区。她感到不自在。但他们就是没想到，因为这就像是，这到底是哪个F代码啊，伙计？这是什么诊断？他们知道得太多了，反而有点当局者迷。绝对是这样。你说得太对了，确实如此，而且我当时就是想要那样，我只是想
focus on the clinical treatment of that person centered one person at a time like that was my that was my bread and butter and that's what i loved but it it doesn't work we do have to have a blend of zooming out and paying attention um and we it's a it's a flawed intellectualizing of everything. Right. Not that complicated. Like, we just have to take a look around and realize, you know, what's really going on here. But that's a great that's a great example. Yeah, I love that idea.
专注于以人为本的临床治疗，一次只关注一个人，这曾是我的立身之本，也是我所热爱的，但它行不通。我们确实需要将“宏观审视”与“微观关注”结合起来，我们对一切事物的过度理智化是有缺陷的。没错，没那么复杂。我们只需要环顾四周，意识到这里到底发生了什么。这是一个很好的例子，我喜欢这个想法。
That's a great system change idea. We need to blend what works great in social work and what works great in clinical counseling and have some overlap there and learn from each other. I had a mentor when I was in graduate school who runs a pretty well-established private practice in Portland, Maine. And he said, you know, one thing that social workers do awesome that us counselors don't do well at all is network and connect with each other and, you know, create like this network of folks who are all sort of trying to champion or paying attention to the same things going on. Counselors historically have not done that very well. So, and, and my
这是一个很棒的系统变革思路。我们需要将社会工作中的优秀实践与临床咨询中的优秀实践结合起来，寻求重叠并相互学习。我在读研究生时有一位导师，他在缅因州波特兰经营着一家相当成熟的私人诊所。他说，社会工作者做得非常出色而我们咨询师做得完全不够的一点，就是建立人脉和相互联系，创造一个由志同道合、关注同样问题的人组成的网络。咨询师在历史上一直做得不太好。所以，我的
whole thing is like, I don't care what your letters are after your name. Like if you identify at all with like being a helper or healer, working in healthcare whatsoever, like we can find a way to align. And I care a lot less about what the letters are after your name as like what your values are and how we can, you know, all show up to this conversation. Yeah. And I think the letters and the trainings and the CEs and that I'm triple, double, extra special certified in this thing, that tendency feeds into the worst insecurities in the profession and it makes such
全部观点是，我不在乎你名字后面是什么头衔。只要你认同自己是一名助人者或疗愈者，从事任何医疗保健工作，我们就能找到合作的方式。我更看重你的价值观，以及我们如何共同参与这场对话，而不是你名字后面的头衔。我认为，那些头衔、培训、继续教育学分，以及“我在某方面获得了三重、双重、超特别认证”的倾向，只会助长行业内最糟糕的不安全感，并造就出
bad clinicians. I mean, I would so much rather bring somebody on with our collective who is like, oh, I read Albert Ellis and I like this about him but I don't like that. But what I do when I get to the part where he doesn't work is I use French pearls and I like a shot. And somebody who's read and integrated all this stuff, like that person's
糟糕的临床医生。比起那些读过并整合了所有理论的人，我更愿意让那些会说“我读过阿尔伯特·埃利斯，我喜欢他这一点，但不喜欢那一点，当他的理论行不通时，我会用法国珍珠（French pearls）和注射疗法”的人加入我们的团队。那个人
going to be a hundred times better of a clinician than the person who's like, who's like, I've done five years of training in DBT. I'm DBT level 8 million and here's all the paper. So they, I mean, that just doesn't tell me very much about if you're any good with a patient or if you can solve a problem that you can't solve, which is really to me, like the trick of the profession is like, you keep bumping into problems that you can't solve and then you need to know how to solve that well if you think you can do everything you're never there you know and um i mean like going back to you talking about systems and all this stuff i mean so many of the like you know cures for the anxiety or when i just point out something that the person doesn't really want to admit that
会比那些说“我完成了五年DBT培训，我是DBT八百万级专家，这是我的所有证书”的人强上一百倍。这些证书并不能告诉我你是否擅长对待病人，或者你是否能解决那些无法解决的问题。对我来说，这才是该行业的诀窍：你不断遇到无法解决的问题，然后你需要知道如何妥善处理。如果你认为自己无所不能，那你永远无法达到那种境界。回到你谈论的系统问题，很多时候，所谓的焦虑“疗法”，其实就是我指出了一些对方不愿承认、
they don't want to like feel and it's not that there's a solution or you need a cognitive or behavioral change. It's just like, yeah, man, like it does you like it does feel like you're in a sinking cruise ship of a country. You know, like, I'm, I've made it, I guess, and I'm looking at the cost of American cheese. And I'm like, what, how do I do this? And by design, you will not hear about these problems on the news or in the paper, like you look at it it's going to be like well actually here's a secret reason why you're gaslighting yourself and you really you're you have lots of money and inflation's not real or you know which bathroom and disney movie is allowed this week i mean it's this aesthetic social stuff that not that there's nothing to it or that we shouldn't have an opinion on those
不愿感受的东西。这并不是说有一个解决方案，或者你需要进行认知或行为上的改变。这只是在说：“伙计，感觉就像身处一艘正在下沉的游轮上，对吧？”你知道，我虽然成功了，但我看着美国奶酪的价格，心想：我该怎么活下去？按照设计，你不会在新闻或报纸上听到这些问题。如果你去查，他们会说：“其实，你是在自我煤气灯效应（gaslighting），你其实很有钱，通货膨胀不是真的，或者这周迪士尼电影里允许出现哪个洗手间。”这些都是审美层面的社会议题，并不是说它们毫无意义或我们不该有意见，
but to take away the it's a distraction from the structural failure of this place yep and and people feel that and i'm just like yeah that's that's it i can't say anything about it but you know a lot of the way wealth and or i can't really do anything about it but a lot of the way wealth and power works this stuff goes back to the bronze age probably not changing how can you and your kids be okay in this world let's figure that out because but it's like people don't the anxiety is created by not quite looking at the sun because it's too bright to look at and i can't do it and when you just bring that into the room and give them permission they're like oh okay you know but it's us trying not to know what we know if that makes sense i don't know yeah you know and
但这些议题分散了人们对这个地方结构性失败的注意力。没错，人们能感觉到这一点，我只能说：“是的，就是这样。”虽然我对此无能为力，但财富和权力的运作方式从青铜时代起可能就没变过。我们该如何让你和你的孩子在这个世界上过得好？让我们来解决这个问题。焦虑的产生是因为人们不敢直视太阳，因为它太刺眼了。当你把这一点带入咨询室并给予他们许可时，他们会说：“哦，原来如此。”这其实是我们试图不去知道我们已知的事实，如果这说得通的话。
and a lot of that is like bringing it back to core counseling you you know, skills, like just being able to, to hold that with somebody and like not trying to fix or change. I feel like a lot of times we're always trying to fix or change. And sometimes that's the absolute last thing we need to do. Like it's holding it, it's validating it. It's saying like, you're not crazy. This is happening. Like the price of things, you know, is going up insanely and inflation, you know, is out of control. And like, yeah, there are all these societal structures that are causing a lot, you know, of mental health struggles and therapy was never designed to be a solution for systemic failure. And that seems to be what we are all asked to do as mental health professionals is prop up all of these conditions that are surfacing as a result of people being really oppressed by systemic design.
很多时候，这又回到了核心咨询技能上，比如能够与某人共同承担这份感受，而不是试图去修复或改变。我觉得很多时候我们总是试图修复或改变，而有时这恰恰是我们最不该做的事。我们需要的是接纳和验证，是告诉对方：“你没疯，这一切确实正在发生。”比如物价飞涨、通货膨胀失控。确实，所有这些社会结构正在导致许多心理健康问题，而治疗从来就不是为了解决系统性失败而设计的。作为心理健康专业人士，我们被要求去支撑这些因系统性压迫而产生的状况，这似乎就是我们被要求做的事情。
You know, we are in sort of, as I think everyone probably in history feels that they're living in a unique time period. And the thing that feels unique to me is how, you know, I wrote about, you know, the, the, the invisible power of excessive wealth, um, last week, I think this very small number of Americans, zero, you know, 0.1% of all Americans is controlling the wealth of like more than half of, you know, our, our GDP, you know, of, of, of all of American wealth that this country holds. And it's up to them. They're the ones that are really dictating how these systems operate, why they're so dysfunctional. There's a lot of political overlap with all of these things. Our food system, the way food is grown and manufactured, healthcare, justice system, all of it. It's to benefit know, healthcare, justice system, like all of it. It's to benefit very, very, very, very wealthy people. And if past a certain amount of capital, you make money in a recession. You're not afraid of it. Why would you care if you can profit off
你知道，我认为历史上每个人都觉得他们生活在一个独特的时代。对我来说，独特之处在于，我上周写到了过度财富的隐形力量。极少数美国人，占总人口0.1%的人，控制着超过一半的美国GDP，也就是这个国家持有的所有财富。这取决于他们。他们才是真正决定这些系统如何运作、为何如此功能失调的人。所有这些事物之间都有很多政治重叠。我们的食品系统、食品的种植和制造方式、医疗保健、司法系统，所有这些都是为了让那些极其富有的人受益。一旦资本超过一定数额，你在经济衰退中也能赚钱。你根本不怕衰退。如果你能从中获利，你为什么要关心呢？
of that? Yeah. And I mean, all the money injected from COVID, like all those COVID relief funds, I mean, healthcare CEOs made more money than they've ever made from all that COVID. But we didn't talk about that. We talked about how somehow people weren't working nine months later because that little $1,500 stimulus check they got, they somehow had been able to live on that. So they just didn't need to work. I was like, man, can you tell me how people are paying rent, water, power, gas, and food without... Can you tell me how people are paying rent, water, power, gas, and food? We need to get these people some budgeting classes because I want to figure out how they're stretching that stimulus check for eight months.
是的。还有从新冠疫情中注入的所有资金，那些救济金，医疗保健行业的CEO们从疫情中赚到的钱比以往任何时候都多。但我们没谈论这个。我们谈论的是为什么九个月后人们还不去工作，好像他们拿到的那1500美元刺激支票足够他们生活一样。我当时就想：“伙计，你能告诉我人们是怎么在不工作的情况下支付房租、水电、燃气和食品费用的吗？”我们需要给这些人开一些预算课程，因为我想弄清楚他们是怎么把那张支票撑过八个月的。
I kind of refuse to watch news. I've reached that point in my life. I'll read news. I like reading and information, but I really can't watch what's being said. It's a dog and pony show. It's a distraction. I mean, there's not news on the news, which is a weird development. Yeah. So it's interesting. There's the digital age and the age of information that we're in, and yet we all are struggling to figure out what's real. It's causing a lot of problems.
我拒绝看新闻，我已经到了人生的这个阶段。我会阅读新闻，我喜欢阅读和获取信息，但我真的无法观看那些评论。那是一场闹剧，是一种干扰。新闻里已经没有新闻了，这是一种奇怪的发展。所以这很有趣，我们处于数字时代和信息时代，但我们都在努力弄清楚什么是真实的。这导致了很多问题。
Well, you've talked a lot about the kind of emotional and uh effect of the systems on the providers and on the patients but you know practically what would things what kind of changes would you advocate for which is a big question i mean there's like i'm sure that there's something against like unionizing essentially in the insurance contract like if you tried to go get all the the therapists in in alabama to say hey blue cross you got to raise our rates or else we're just going to leave your network and they couldn't have no private practice people they couldn't survive with just hospitals and big clinics you know what um well you know what what are the kind of collect because you talk a lot
你谈了很多关于系统对提供者和患者的情感影响，但实际上，你会倡导什么样的改变？这是一个大问题。我敢肯定，保险合同中存在反对工会化的条款。如果你试图让阿拉巴马州所有的治疗师联合起来说：“嘿，蓝十字保险，你必须提高我们的费率，否则我们就退出你的网络。”他们无法离开私人诊所，他们无法仅靠医院和大型诊所生存。那么，你们谈论的集体……
about you diagnose a lot of the problems with labor um you know taproot was a kind of a different experimental structure to try and basically do an experiment to see if we could do a thing where labor owned the practice. But a lot of that stuff, it has to be an experiment because there's not a lot of... We have been moving in such a bad direction for a long time. We've got to try something new. Do you have any ideas there? So I like to talk about what I think would have worked for me better when I was practicing as a clinician or what I think would help me stay longer because that definitely is still real, a real hurt and a pain, you know,
你诊断出很多劳工问题。Taproot是一种不同的实验性结构，试图进行实验，看看我们是否能实现由劳动者拥有诊所。但很多事情必须是实验性的，因为我们已经朝着错误的方向走了太久。我们必须尝试新事物。你有什么想法吗？我喜欢谈论我认为在我作为临床医生执业时对我更有帮助的事情，或者我认为能帮助我坚持更久的事情，因为那种伤害和痛苦是真实存在的。
that I felt that I had to leave to just like find a way to survive, find a way to make money to pay our bills. And we own a house. And the reason we own a house is in part because I left clinical practice and found my way to make more stable money elsewhere. There is a deep pain in me still that I had to leave. I did not want to. And I have anger and hurt and resentment. But one of the things I think would have worked really well for me does not exist. I've never heard of this existing is being able to see a much lower volume of people on a daily or weekly basis. I'm a highly sensitive person. I think a lot of people who are helpers and healers are intuitive empaths, you know, tend to trend
我感到我不得不离开，只是为了寻找生存之道，寻找赚钱支付账单的方法。我们有房子，而我们拥有房子的部分原因是我离开了临床实践，找到了更稳定的收入来源。我内心深处依然有一种痛苦，因为我不得不离开。我不想离开。我有愤怒、伤害和怨恨。但我认为对我非常有效的一件事目前并不存在，我从未听说过它的存在，那就是每天或每周接待更少量的病人。我是一个高度敏感的人。我认为许多助人者和疗愈者都是直觉型共情者，往往倾向于
towards being sensitive folks and seeing six, seven, eight people every day literally made me sick. It was just too much on my nervous system. I didn't quite know that at the time. Cause like, you know, when you're entrenched in that survival mode, you can't, you can't take that 30,000 foot view. You don't have time. You don't have the energy to really realize what's not working and why. And when I got to private practice, I did sort of taper down. And I found that if I was able to see four people a day was like a really good sweet spot for me. And especially if I work well in the morning. So like if I could see four folks in the morning or by early afternoon, and then, you know, be able to talk to my supervisor for like an hour or more about like
成为敏感的人。每天接待六、七、八个人真的让我生病了。这对我的神经系统来说负担太重了。当时我并不完全明白这一点，因为当你陷入那种生存模式时，你无法从三万英尺的高度审视问题。你没有时间，也没有精力去真正意识到什么行不通以及为什么。当我进入私人诊所时，我确实减少了工作量。我发现如果我每天能接待四个人，那对我来说是一个非常好的平衡点。特别是如果我上午工作效率高的话。如果我能在上午或下午早些时候接待四个人，然后能和我的主管谈论一个小时或更长时间，讨论我在那些会话中脑子里闪过的所有事情，
all the things that was going through my mind about those sessions I just had, you know, um, that would have been so much better of a structure for me over the longterm if I was able to do that. Um, and then what I really think would be awesome now, um, is if I could build in like a couple hours of writing, like creating blog post content for somebody or something like that, you know, so having like this blended approach, I think to clinician work, we're like, yes, we're doing direct service work, but that's not the only thing, you know, that we're doing, we can change it up. And so our days can look different. You know, I think we need that variety to really feel like we still are having an art form to this practice that we're doing. I think that's really important. So I haven't seen or heard of positions like that. I think
那对我长期的结构来说会好得多。而且，我现在认为非常棒的一点是，如果我能安排几个小时的写作时间，比如为某人创作博客内容之类的。我认为这种混合式的方法对临床工作很有帮助，我们不仅在做直接服务工作，我们还可以改变它。所以我们的日子可以看起来不同。我认为我们需要这种多样性，才能真正感觉到我们所做的实践中仍然有一种艺术形式。我认为这非常重要。所以我还没见过或听说过这样的职位。我想
that probably would only exist in private practice, but that sort of blended model. I think if we could find a way to make that work structurally, I think it could really invite a lot of people who have left this industry for dead back to practice. Well, and I think too, one of the things is that like, I wish insurance would pay for two-hour sessions because you could see a lower volume of that. And with trauma and a lot of complex trauma and relational therapy, like I think less therapy for longer works better you know but they won't pay for the two-hour session so the patient either is on the hook for that and the insurance pays for the first hour but like why would you pay for why would you
这可能只存在于私人诊所中，但那种混合模式，如果我们能在结构上找到实现的方法，我认为它真的可以吸引许多已经对这个行业死心的人回到实践中来。而且我认为，我希望保险公司能为两小时的会话付费，因为这样你可以接待更少的人。对于创伤、复杂的创伤和关系治疗，我认为更长时间的治疗效果更好，但他们不会为两小时的会话付费。所以病人要么自己承担费用，要么保险只支付第一小时。但为什么你会……
say okay you can come seven days a week to see this therapist and we'll pay for it you just can't come twice every two weeks you know you know you can come for a two-hour session every two weeks we won't pay for that but you can come for a two-hour session every two weeks we won't pay for that but you can come literally seven days a week and the claims will sail through i mean why it doesn't make sense you know and and it's really frustrating because now we have the data on outpatient services we have the data that shows and this is from like ever north um which is owned by etna or i forget yeah um but they did studies and showed that when people have access consistent access to outpatient therapy they get better not just in their mental health but also in their physical health the volume of their claims
为什么你会说“好吧，你可以每周七天来看这位治疗师，我们会支付费用”，但你不能每两周来两次？你知道，你可以每两周进行一次两小时的会话，我们不会支付费用，但你可以每周七天都来，索赔申请会顺利通过。这根本说不通。这真的很令人沮丧，因为现在我们有了门诊服务的数据。Evernorth（由安泰保险拥有）的研究表明，当人们能够持续获得门诊治疗时，他们的心理健康和身体健康都会好转，他们的索赔量
goes down they are less costly to manage year over year so not just in the first year of receiving therapy but if they receive therapy in the second year those So not just in the first year of receiving therapy, but if they receive therapy in the second year, those cost savings go down even further year over year when individuals have access to outpatient mental health services. So the proof is already there that is extremely cost effective for managed care to be paying almost with opening the floodgates entirely without any of this red tape at all, it would actually cost them less to manage patients, you know, financially over their mental and physical health if they just gave unrestricted access to mental health therapy.
会下降。他们每年的管理成本会降低，不仅是在接受治疗的第一年，如果他们在第二年继续接受治疗，这些成本节省会逐年进一步增加。所以，证据已经表明，对于管理式医疗来说，完全开放门诊心理健康治疗，没有任何繁文缛节，实际上在财务上管理病人的成本会更低。如果他们只是提供不受限制的心理健康治疗，这在财务上是划算的。
So it would literally be a win-win. There is literally a win-win that exists in this system that they are not willing to engage in whatsoever. Well, like I did business consulting before I did social work and some of the, I mean, you'll get with the owners of these businesses where it's like they're spending all this money. But when you tell them, Hey, look, you screwing this person over in this situation is actually costing you money because you're not keeping talent or whatever. It's like, they can't get it. And a lot of those forces insurance is the same. It's like, I mean, you have literally literal research saying that this is cheaper for them and they can't swallow the initial expense because it feels
所以这实际上是一个双赢。在这个系统中确实存在一个双赢的局面，但他们根本不愿意参与。我在做社会工作之前做过商业咨询，你会遇到那些企业主，他们花了很多钱。但当你告诉他们：“嘿，看，你在这种情况下压榨这个人实际上是在让你亏钱，因为你留不住人才。”他们就是无法理解。很多保险公司也是如此。明明有研究表明这对他们更便宜，但他们无法承受最初的支出，因为这感觉
like they lost or there's some way around that or, you know, that profit seeking, whatever. And it's like, you know, y'all are requiring me to use evidence-based practice as the insurance company. Why aren't you using it? There isn't any because it's all about risk management. You know, I've been inside. I've worked for health insurers. You know, not super high up, but high up enough to ask difficult questions and get shitty answers about them. Yeah.
像是他们输了，或者有某种规避方法，或者那种追求利润的心理。他们要求我作为保险公司使用循证实践，为什么你们自己不用呢？因为这完全是关于风险管理。我曾在健康保险公司工作过。虽然职位不是特别高，但足够高到可以提出尖锐的问题并得到糟糕的回答。
And it's all about containing costs because there's a quarterly earnings report that has to go out to stockholders. That is more important than the long-term profitability of the company, the quarter. We have these such perverse incentives. That's what it's about. Well, I was curious if you, because I do think that the newer generation seems to be open to new ideas. They don't have the insecurity of like, oh, you're doing something new. Did mommy and daddy say you could do that?
这一切都是为了控制成本，因为有一份季度收益报告必须发给股东。这比公司的长期盈利能力更重要。我们有如此扭曲的激励机制，这就是问题的所在。我很好奇，因为我确实认为新一代似乎对新想法持开放态度。他们没有那种“哦，你在做新东西，爸爸妈妈允许你这么做吗？”的不安全感。
That I see in some of these older professionals that i butt heads with and um you know so with taproot like my practice like the the goal of it was to be kind of i mean one we wanted to be different than the this kind of cbt practice and and the kind of boomer like zen rock stacked up gentle gentle time this is a safe space and so our brand was a little bolder it was like yeah we do state-of-the-art you know uh complex trauma neuroscientific approaches but also um you know this therapy can be part of life and art and growth and cool and it doesn't have to you have to be like a hurt puppy you know coming in here like sometimes i feel like that language keeps more people out you know that we have to make you know you know it's a safe space but it
我在一些与我意见不合的老一辈专业人士身上看到了这一点。所以对于Taproot，我的诊所，目标是与众不同。我们不想成为那种CBT诊所，也不想成为那种像婴儿潮一代那样堆着禅石、温柔地说“这是一个安全空间”的地方。我们的品牌更大胆，我们说：“是的，我们做最先进的复杂创伤神经科学方法。”但同时，这种治疗也可以是生活、艺术和成长的一部分，它很酷，你不必像一只受伤的小狗一样走进这里。有时我觉得那种语言反而把更多人拒之门外。我们必须说这是一个安全空间，但
also is like you don't you there's something that gets a little bit performative sometimes. Um, and then, and so, uh, the structure of it was, you know, that we were going to do, we don't look like a normal thing where there's the little target light and whatever. I mean, we wanted it to, um, because we, everyone was trained in brain spotting, which is very expensive. Everybody was trained in phase two of brain spotting. We have the QEG brain mapping and neuromodulation clinic downstairs. We are now getting trained in ETT, which is really neat. Another brain-based medicine. And then we're one of the few places where you can get all of those with somatic and experiential models that everyone has at least one of those. So we kind of are building these protocols to
它有时也显得有点表演性质。所以，我们的结构是，我们看起来不像那种有小目标灯的普通诊所。我们每个人都接受过脑点（Brainspotting）培训，这非常昂贵。每个人都接受了脑点第二阶段的培训。我们楼下有QEG脑图和神经调节诊所。我们现在正在接受ETT培训，这真的很棒，是另一种基于大脑的医学。我们是少数几个能将所有这些与躯体和体验模型结合起来的地方之一，每个人至少掌握其中一种。所以我们正在建立这些协议来
figure out like what works better, you know, like we know if it's asd brain spotting may not work right away but then with the neuromodulation we can now use brain spotting to treat trauma but the trauma it has to be done in this order with a during a little condition and things and that isn't something that you um see everywhere because people tend to just be doing one kind of therapy. But then from a business perspective, I really believe that in that labor, you know, has right stone structure, like I really was never gotten offers to run businesses that I turned down, because I just think the revolving door model of like, I'm going to take 60% of your income, and then an extra 10 to 15% in made up fees, until you can go compete against me and then leave and then an extra 10 to 15% in made up fees until you can go compete against me and then leave. And then you go into private practice and then I'll hire another one of you. And I have all
弄清楚什么更有效。比如我们知道如果是ASD，脑点可能不会立即起作用，但通过神经调节，我们现在可以使用脑点来治疗创伤，但创伤必须按照这个顺序在特定条件下进行。这不是你在到处都能看到的，因为人们往往只做一种治疗。但从商业角度来看，我真的相信劳动者拥有诊所结构。我拒绝过运行其他企业的邀请，因为我不喜欢那种“我要拿走你收入的60%，再加上10%到15%的虚构费用，直到你可以去和我竞争然后离开”的旋转门模式。然后你进入私人诊所，我再雇佣另一个你。我拥有
the patients and people know who I am. And I'll deign to give you some for, you know, more than half your income. Like I just, I don't like that model. So what we wanted to do with Taproot was have a collectively owned practice where, you know, on paper, it's a 1099 contractor thing, but we take young people who they were that I can talk to and be like, this person knows what's up, but the hospital is not going to value you for a long time, but we'll invest in you now. And we don't make money on you for a year or two years. So we really need you happy. You know, like I'm putting myself over a barrel because if we just spend all this money to do a designer office for you and prefer personalized marketing and set
所有的病人，人们知道我是谁。我屈尊给你一些病人，换取你一半以上的收入。我不喜欢那种模式。所以我们想用Taproot做的是建立一个集体拥有的诊所。在纸面上，它是1099承包商模式，但我们招募年轻人，我能和他们交流，知道这个人有潜力，虽然医院暂时不会重视你，但我们现在就投资你。我们一两年内不从你身上赚钱。所以我们真的需要你快乐。我把自己置于险境，因为如果我们花这么多钱为你做设计办公室、个性化营销和设置
you up your brand and you just take it and walk. Then I'm hosed. So like I'm like, we really want to keep you happy. And so because of that, we tried to be really lean and mean and to automate as much stuff as we can and to not have like a lot of like, you know, administrative and W2 overhead and work smarter, not harder. And then if we make extra money, we pay it back to the clinicians as a bonus at the end of the year. But what that did was, one, we're not all by ourself. You know, we're not just like, okay, well, I'm, I'm made it in private practice. So now I'm by myself, like it actually is a functioning clinic where we all can collaborate and do these things, kind of like an institute in a way that you can't at those other practices, because the people who are good are leaving you know um and then two um like people can do things like you're talking about like i like to write and do the podcast which wouldn't really be a cosp opposition that made any sense for me but it fills up it does all
你的品牌，而你拿了就走，那我就完了。所以我说，我们真的想让你快乐。因此，我们尽量精简，尽可能自动化，没有太多的行政和W2管理开销，聪明地工作，而不是更辛苦地工作。如果我们赚了额外的钱，我们在年底以奖金的形式返还给临床医生。这样做的好处是，第一，我们不是孤军奋战。它实际上是一个功能齐全的诊所，我们可以协作，像一个研究所一样，这是其他诊所做不到的，因为优秀的人都在离开。第二，人们可以做你谈论的事情，比如我喜欢写作和做播客，这在其他地方可能说不通，但它填补了
of this wonderful seo that would cost 15 20 000 if we went out and bought it but i can produce content people like and that's benefiting the other clinicians so they understand so i'm kind of i get paid for that and then you know like some of them have more administrative um or networking or you know whatever and in private practice none of those skills would get used you know um because there's no reason for me to continue to have a podcast i'm already full in a year so why would i do that you know but it lets you break that up and everybody's strengths kind of shine so i hope that that collectivized thing is something that happens. But I really, really just didn't want anyone to work for me if they would make more money not working for me. There'd be no reason for that to happen. Yeah. Well, thank you for sharing that,
所有这些美妙的SEO，如果我们花钱买的话要15到20万美元，但我可以制作人们喜欢的内容，这对其他临床医生也有利。所以我因此获得报酬，而且他们中的一些人有更多的行政、网络或其他技能。在私人诊所，这些技能都用不上，因为我没有理由继续做播客，我一年后就满了，为什么要那样做呢？但这让你分担了工作，每个人的优势都能闪光。我希望这种集体化模式能实现。我真的不想让任何人如果能在别处赚更多钱却还在为我工作。那没有理由发生。是的，谢谢你的分享，
because I think that's the type of innovation that we need to be looking at together, you know, that we could invest in people who are up and coming, who have something to look forward to. You know, like I've heard from like a lot of clinicians I consult with, especially newer clinicians, they're like, so what's the goal here? What's my overarching goal here? Just see as many patients as possible as long as as I possibly can, until I can't do it anymore. Like, that doesn't feel very good as a clinician who wants to grow their skills and get really good at something. I imagine the fact that you're using actual devices helps to destigmatize and break up some of the drone of all talk therapy, you know, on overload, on repeat all the time. You know, those are some really wonderful things that you're doing there.
因为我认为这是我们需要共同关注的创新类型，我们可以投资于那些有前途、有盼头的年轻人。我从我咨询的许多临床医生那里听说，特别是较新的临床医生，他们会问：“这里的目标是什么？我的总体目标是什么？就是尽可能多地看病人，直到我再也做不动为止吗？”作为一个想要提升技能并精通某项技术的临床医生，这感觉并不好。我想你们使用实际设备有助于去污名化，打破所有谈话疗法那种单调、过载、重复的循环。这些都是你们正在做的非常棒的事情。
I hope I'm interested if you're tracking that in any way or how you're seeing, you know, clinician mental health sort of improve as maybe compared to other environments they're coming from. I'm always looking for a problem. So I'm like always terrified they're going to leave and are like, what can we do? And we're like, we're happy. Calm down, you know, whatever. So, I mean, so far, nobody who's joined Taproot has ever left. But there's nothing in our contract.
我很好奇你是否在以某种方式追踪这一点，或者你如何观察到临床医生的心理健康与他们来自的其他环境相比有所改善。我总是寻找问题，所以我总是担心他们会离开，心想：“我们能做什么？”他们说：“我们很开心，冷静点。”所以到目前为止，加入Taproot的人从来没有离开过。但我们的合同里没有任何限制。
There's no non-compete. There's no buyout. There's no punitive, whatever. I mean, if you don't want to work here, take all the patients that you have, walk,, our management to make sure that everything there is always keeping them happy and making them more money than they would make on their own. Because the second that they can, they should leave. Like, if you can make more money, then not at Taproot. But we're able to bundle, you know, very professional, like, billing and admin services and all of these. We have a huge professional library. Like we're able to provide trainings, um, you know, on a larger scale cheaper because we're bundled together than anybody could individually go out and get all that stuff. You know, that's, that's awesome.
没有竞业禁止，没有买断，没有惩罚性条款。如果你不想在这里工作，带走你所有的病人，走吧。我们的管理层确保一切都在让他们快乐，让他们赚得比自己单干更多。因为一旦他们能赚更多，他们就应该离开。如果你在Taproot之外能赚更多，那就去吧。但我们能够捆绑非常专业的计费和行政服务。我们有一个巨大的专业图书馆。我们能够以更大的规模、更便宜的价格提供培训，因为我们捆绑在一起，比个人去获取所有这些东西要好。这太棒了。
I think that just your lens of like empowerment, autonomy, like wanting people to learn skills that they can be self-sovereign with, whether they stay with you or not, you know, that level of, um, self-empowerment, I think clinicians need everywhere, far and wide. And it's just, it's just really rare to find that. So I appreciate what you're doing. Well, I mean, I, I don't know if that works. I mean, so far everyone else has made more money. They haven't left. That's a really good. Well, but they have, they've made more money than they would have if they hadn't, if they had not joined, like they made more money being a part of Taproot, but I've made less money trying to start this whole project.
我认为你的赋权和自主权的视角，想要人们学习能够实现自我主权的技能，无论他们是否留下来，那种自我赋权的水平，我认为临床医生到处都需要。这真的很难找到。所以我很欣赏你所做的一切。我不知道这是否有效。到目前为止，其他人赚了更多的钱，他们没有离开。这很好。他们赚的钱比他们如果不加入Taproot要多，但我为了启动整个项目赚得更少。
Like, cause I, you know, like it, maybe if it works out in the long run, you know, all that, that's a nice thing to have a piece of, but in the short term, I mean, it's been like an investment, you know, it's not something I don't I'm not making what they're making. So it's still experimental. Yeah. Yeah. But I think we're going to have to run those experiments, you know, and we've learned a ton about how to be leaner. Like you look at our overhead and what we're able to provide with what we spend based on practices that are four or five times our size, like they should able to be leaner. Well, this is something I've heard too, that practices could operate on leaner margins than they do. And that's why, you know, even in these group practices or private practices, there can still be exploitation that exists unnecessarily. I didn't really know that.
因为这是一个投资，不是我赚了他们赚的钱。所以它仍然是实验性的。但我们必须进行这些实验，我们学到了很多关于如何精简的知识。看看我们的开销，以及我们基于比我们大四五倍的诊所所能提供的服务，他们应该能够更精简。这是我听到的，诊所可以在比现在更精简的利润率下运作。这就是为什么即使在这些团体诊所或私人诊所中，仍然可能存在不必要的剥削。我以前真的不知道。
And still I started talking to some practice owners who were like, yeah, we can offer like an 80-20 split and still be totally cool on our books. Especially when you're a teletherapy firm and you're not even the rent and all of that. I mean, if anyone's not familiar with the market, like the way that, I mean, there's W-2 practices that act like they're God's gift to pay a new $30,000 or something. And then there's these 1099 contractor practices where you're your own company but they're going to refer and manage for you but they pay you you know usually about 60 of what you make but then you never actually get that in practice at a lot of the firms around here some are better than others but
直到我开始和一些诊所老板交谈，他们说：“是的，我们可以提供80-20的分成，账面上依然完全没问题。”特别是当你是一家远程治疗公司，甚至不需要支付租金时。如果有人不熟悉这个市场，有些W-2诊所表现得好像他们是上帝的恩赐，给新人支付3万美元左右。然后是这些1099承包商诊所，你是你自己的公司，但他们会为你推荐和管理，他们通常支付你收入的60%，但你永远拿不到那么多，因为很多公司……
i mean the ones that like me and my friends have worked at it was like oh you didn't lock your notes on a sunday when you didn't have any notes to lock but you didn't hit the lock button so that's five percent fee and just do like it just stuff designed to scam money because that's how they make money and they don't care if you leave and it's in your contract and if you want to leave early you got to pay me and buy out of it and and so i mean on paper we are a 1099 contractor practice like we're all individual companies but the structure is more to protect them and let them run it. And everyone gets a piece of what the whole total project makes at the end of the year. So you're incentivized to take some time to learn how the QEG works, you know, help set up a referral stream for them so that more people in the community know about it because you get a part of it. And the hope is that, you know, everybody is able to make more together than we ever would have individually. And, you know, content creator,
我和朋友工作过的地方，就像是“哦，你周日没锁笔记，虽然你那天没笔记要锁，但你没按锁键，所以这是5%的罚款”。这只是为了骗钱，因为他们就是这样赚钱的，他们不在乎你是否离开，合同里写着如果你想提前离开，你得付钱买断。所以，在纸面上，我们是1099承包商诊所，我们都是独立公司，但结构更多是为了保护他们。每个人在年底都能分到整个项目总收入的一部分。所以你被激励去花时间学习QEG如何工作，帮助建立推荐流，因为你也能从中受益。希望大家在一起能比单独工作赚得更多。而且，内容创作，
you know, being like a thing that a lot of therapists do it when they start, but then they stop because they're full and they don't need to get their brand any bigger. But because we're all writing articles and doing podcasts and contributing, like we could have an online store where we sell wellness products. I mean, there's a lot of things we can do with our national reach now that they would all kind of have a part of. and i think those kind of collective structures are things we need to to work on but collectivism doesn't mean everyone's doing the same thing you know it means you find people with the skills you need and share it yeah it almost almost means the opposite to me like the collective means like maybe generally all trying to push the ball forward but in a variety of different ways you
这是很多治疗师开始时会做的事情，但后来他们停下来了，因为他们满了，不需要扩大品牌。但因为我们都在写文章、做播客和贡献，我们可以有一个在线商店，销售健康产品。我们现在有全国性的影响力，可以做很多事情。我认为这种集体结构是我们需要的，但集体主义并不意味着每个人都在做同样的事情，这意味着你找到拥有你需要技能的人并分享它。是的，对我来说，它几乎意味着相反的意思。集体意味着大家都在努力推动球向前，但以各种不同的方式。
know like this is an experiment for you and i'm'm sure like you said, you've gleaned so many insights from this. You know, how else are we supposed to move, you know, our professions forward if we're not trying new things, you know? So yeah, I really like that. And, you know, I talk a lot about 1099s and I don't mean to suggest that it's not a good thing. I think there's value there. Like you've obviously built a lot of value into what you're offering to clinicians and they know that upfront. And so that's a symbiotic relationship. If that works, I love that. But what I see is a lot of these bigger companies saying, well, we can't afford insurance. So here you go. And we're still going to tell you that you need to do CBT with all your clients and you have a caseload that is way too much for you and you know what i mean so 1099s can go a different route but they're definitely
这是一个实验，我相信你从中获得了许多见解。如果我们不尝试新事物，我们还能如何推动我们的职业向前发展呢？所以我真的很喜欢这一点。我谈论了很多关于1099的问题，我并不是说它不好。我认为它有价值。你显然在你提供给临床医生的服务中注入了大量价值，他们事先就知道这一点。这是一种共生关系。如果这有效，我喜欢。但我看到很多大公司说：“我们负担不起保险，所以给你这个。”我们仍然会告诉你，你需要对所有客户进行CBT，你的病例量太大，你知道我的意思吗？所以1099可以走不同的路线，但它们绝对
usually kind of exploitive a way to turn the profession into gig work which is what they're trying and that's what's scary to me is you look at like something like better help that the the lefty good guy on the podcast is saying mental health awareness and then they roll their sponsored ad for better health or something and it's like these companies that want to reach across state lines and say that they're the same as therapy and all of that. I mean, that seems like the scariest thing for me is somebody trying to turn, you know, social work into Uber basically. Yeah. Or, and with AI, you know, literally they're already trying to replace, you know, the work of human connection with AI. And there's lots of things AI can be leveraged to do, but I don't think we should start with replacing therapeutic work.
通常是剥削性的，是一种将职业变成零工经济的方式，这就是他们正在尝试的，这让我感到害怕。看看像BetterHelp这样的公司，播客里的左派好人说“心理健康意识”，然后他们播放BetterHelp的赞助广告。这些公司想要跨越州界，声称他们和治疗是一样的。对我来说，最可怕的就是有人试图把社会工作变成Uber。是的。或者，随着人工智能的发展，他们已经在试图用人工智能取代人类连接的工作。人工智能可以被利用做很多事情，但我认为我们不应该从取代治疗工作开始。
It doesn't seem like that'll really work out in the long run, but people are trying to do it. Well, and a lot of those companies, it's kind of icky. And what they do is because they'll say, you know, this is therapy, therapy, therapy on their YouTube ad. But then when you go to your paperwork, yeah, this is a licensed therapist, but they're not doing therapy to you. So they're bypassing all of this. And she's going to read the
从长远来看，这似乎行不通，但人们正在尝试这样做。很多公司，这有点恶心。他们会说：“这是治疗，治疗，治疗。”在他们的YouTube广告上。但当你去填文书工作时，是的，这是持证治疗师，但他们并没有对你进行治疗。所以他们绕过了所有这些。她要读那个……
we can speak out and try and say that this is not okay. You know, a lot of it is like clinicians taking back, you know, in some ways ownership of what it means to be a therapist, of what it means to do therapy, what therapy is, not allowing like all these corporations just come in and bastardize it and cut it down into little parts and sell it off. That's not, that's not what any of us came to do. Yeah. But I mean, that takes some political will and some like desire to actually regulate, like when BetterHelp sold people's Facebook and when they sold Facebook therapy notes illegally, which if one provider did that, they would be out of practice. They wouldn't have a license. But for some reason, when you do it with, you know, 4 million people, you're, you, it isn't an existential threat to your existence, you know,
我们可以大声疾呼，试图表明这是不对的。你知道，很大程度上这就像是临床医生在某种程度上夺回了作为治疗师的自主权，夺回了什么是治疗、什么是心理治疗的定义权，而不是任由那些大公司进来将其庸俗化、拆解成碎片并转手倒卖。那不是我们任何一个人入行的初衷。是的。但我的意思是，这需要一些政治意愿和真正去监管的渴望，比如当BetterHelp非法出售人们的Facebook数据和Facebook治疗记录时，如果是一个个体执业者这样做，他们早就被吊销执照了。但出于某种原因，当你对400万人这样做时，这并不会对你的生存构成威胁，你知道的，
or even that inconvenient, they got fined less money than they made selling the data. So, I mean, that's a huge failure of regulation that I don't really see right left any outcry about. Yeah. And it happens. And they even plan for that. Well, we're, they even, they know, they know they're going to have to pay a fine, but they know that it's less than the payout. So there's a lot of darkness in this industry. And I try and balance calling it out with having hope. I think that's important and not just talk about how terrible and bad it feels sometimes, but that there is hope and highlighting people's stories and who's trying to do it right and who's trying to experiment and do new things and keep people in this industry, in this profession, because God knows all of us need helpers and healers in the
甚至连麻烦都算不上，他们被罚的钱比卖数据赚的钱还要少。所以，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的监管失败，我并没有看到左派或右派对此有任何强烈的抗议。是的。这种情况确实发生了。他们甚至预料到了这一点。好吧，他们甚至知道，他们知道自己会被罚款，但他们知道罚款金额少于收益。所以这个行业有很多黑暗面。我试图在揭露这些黑暗面和保持希望之间取得平衡。我认为这很重要，不能只谈论它有时感觉多么糟糕和可怕，而要看到希望，强调人们的故事，谁在尝试正确地做事，谁在尝试实验和做新事物，并让人们留在这一行业、这一职业中，因为上帝知道我们所有人都需要帮助者和治愈者。
world. So I can feel it. I think like the speed of, you know, there's these kind of post-EMDR things that are just really quick, like ETT and brain spotting, especially, I mean, where I see those kind of empowering the profession is that they're just so fast. The cost proposition isn't that much for the patient, even if you charge $300 an hour, because they can get better in a month. And things that used to just take years, it's not an intuitive therapy idea. It's more of a neural neurological, kind of weird thing. And I mean, you're looking at pupillometry and stuff and those things just work for PTSD in weeks and what really used to take years, even with very good therapy because it's not, it's not talk-based. I mean, it's kind of operating somehow directly
世界。所以我能感觉到。我认为像EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）之后出现的一些疗法，比如ETT和脑点疗法（Brainspotting），它们真的很快，尤其是它们在赋能这一职业方面，是因为它们速度太快了。对于患者来说，成本主张并没有那么高，即使你每小时收费300美元，因为他们可能在一个月内就能好转。而那些过去需要数年时间才能解决的问题，这并不是一种直觉上的治疗理念。它更像是一种神经学上的、有点奇特的东西。我的意思是，你观察瞳孔测量法之类的东西，这些东西在几周内就能对创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）起作用，而这在过去即使有非常好的治疗也需要数年时间，因为它不是基于谈话的。我的意思是，它在某种程度上直接作用于
on the brainstem and basal ganglia and like, they're just, there's some exciting new stuff coming. I wish it was more available. I do too. And that's wonderful. And I think we have to be willing to think beyond talk therapies, right? I think that's where we start, but like, we have to be willing to just sort of figure out what else works. I think we're not, a lot of us are not willing to say how little we truly know about the brain, just like where we are in society, in evolution. Like there's so much undiscovered that we know about the brain and what helps and what heals. And it's very individualized. But I think it's super exciting that folks with, you know, licensed clinical social work backgrounds can find their way to learning these specific skills with brain mapping
脑干和基底神经节，而且确实有一些令人兴奋的新事物即将出现。我希望它们能更普及。我也是。这太棒了。我认为我们必须愿意跳出谈话疗法的思维定式，对吧？我认为这是我们的起点，但我们必须愿意去弄清楚还有什么其他方法有效。我认为我们很多人不愿意承认我们对大脑的了解是多么匮乏，就像我们在社会和进化中所处的位置一样。关于大脑以及什么有助于治疗和康复，还有太多未知的领域。而且这非常个性化。但我认为，拥有临床社会工作背景的人能够通过学习这些特定的脑图技能找到自己的方向，这非常令人兴奋，
and bringing people like neurologically essentially based treatments that can help them like heal some really severe symptoms in a really short amount of time. I mean, that's incredible. And I agree, we need to have those accessed in more places and be more widely available. I think one of the worst things we do is get so focused on our little niche that we don't want to pay attention to how the field is growing and all these new things that are happening. And so one of the things that has worked really well for me is to not become too fused with whatever it is that I learn. I always want to learn more and just like keeping that really piqued curiosity about what else is out there, you know, what else could work. I think that's really sort of a recipe for growth when you're willing to sort of keep your head up at what else
并为人们带来本质上基于神经学的治疗，帮助他们在很短的时间内治愈一些非常严重的症状。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。我同意，我们需要在更多地方提供这些治疗，并使其更广泛地普及。我认为我们所做的最糟糕的事情之一就是过于专注于自己的小圈子，而不去关注这个领域是如何发展的，以及所有这些正在发生的新事物。所以对我来说，非常有效的一件事就是不要对我所学的任何东西变得过于固执。我总是想学到更多，保持对外界还有什么其他可能有效的方法的那种强烈好奇心。我认为当你愿意抬头看看还有什么其他东西时，这确实是一种成长的秘诀，
is out there and not just only be focused on the things that we have been trained. Well, I think the traditional hierarchies are as damaging for the people on the bottom of the totem pole than they are on the top. The thing is, I don't know how all of that stuff works. I mean, Jay has two PhDs. Deanna is an electrical engineer PhD. I mean, they run that nervous stem stuff marie does things that i don't know she's got trainings that i don't know i mean if it feels like oh well i want to have this practice and everybody needs to do my same kind of therapy and i need to be the expert and they have to come here and they'll learn from me and then after they've done their time they'll i'll kiss their ring and now they're the whatever like i don't want to hire people who only do
而不仅仅是专注于我们受训时学到的那些东西。嗯，我认为传统的等级制度对处于权力金字塔底层的人造成的伤害，和对顶层的人造成的伤害一样大。问题是，我不知道所有这些东西是如何运作的。我的意思是，Jay有两个博士学位。Deanna是电气工程博士。我的意思是，他们负责那些神经干细胞的东西，Marie做的事情我也不懂，她接受过我不知道的培训。我的意思是，如果感觉像是“哦，好吧，我想拥有这个诊所，每个人都需要做和我一样的治疗，我必须是专家，他们必须来这里，从我这里学习，然后等他们熬够了时间，我就让他们亲吻我的戒指，现在他们就是什么什么了”——我不想要雇佣那些只会做
worse versions of what i know until I want to hire people who are smarter than me, because that's what has allowed us to provide things that I can't alone and to discover things that I couldn't by ourself. And we have so many protocols and integrative, you know, methodologies now that don't exist anywhere, just because we were willing to get out of our comfort zone and be curious and get a bunch of people who were new things the other person didn't and weren't insecure about that together in one space. That's beautiful. And I think that's, that might be the future, right, of where this is all headed is that we don't just exist in silos as professional counselors and social workers and psychologists
我所知技能的拙劣版本的人，我想雇佣比我更聪明的人，因为这正是让我们能够提供我一个人无法提供的服务，并发现我们自己无法发现的东西的原因。我们现在有这么多协议和综合性的方法论，在其他任何地方都不存在，仅仅是因为我们愿意走出舒适区，保持好奇心，并把一群各自擅长不同新事物、且对此并不感到不安的人聚集在一个空间里。这太美妙了。我认为这可能就是未来，对吧？这一切的发展方向不是让我们仅仅作为专业咨询师、社会工作者和心理学家存在于孤岛中，
and psychiatrists, but that we do have these blended approaches where we're going multidisciplinary and we're figuring out, you know, how can we pull from all these different fields and really sort of get that holistic view on how to help people in really innovative ways. Sometimes they're like ancient ways and sometimes they're strikingly innovative ways, but like, how can we take a really holistic approach? So that's really cool what you're doing. And I suspect that those types of approaches will continue to grow. Yeah, I do. I mean, when we opened BrainSpotting, there were two providers in the state almost, and now there's like more than 50 just in our zip codes. In three years, it's really blown up because the market demanded it. And patients don't pay for things that don't work for a long time.
和精神科医生，而是我们拥有这些混合的方法，我们正在走向多学科，我们正在弄清楚，你知道，我们如何从所有这些不同的领域中汲取经验，并真正获得那种帮助人们的整体视角，以真正创新的方式。有时它们是古老的方式，有时是惊人的创新方式，但我们如何采取一种真正整体的方法？所以你所做的事情真的很酷。我怀疑这些类型的方法会继续增长。是的，我也这么认为。我的意思是，当我们开设脑点疗法（BrainSpotting）时，该州几乎只有两名提供者，而现在仅在我们的邮政编码区域内就有超过50名。在三年内，它真的爆发式增长了，因为市场有需求。而且患者不会为长期无效的东西买单。
They don't recommend things that don't work to their friends. That's great. Yeah. Congratulations on that kind of growth. That's really impressive. Well, I mean, we don't have the 50 providers. We're a five-person practice. But I just mean that we brought it here and it kind of fueled demand and people heard about it. And that's great. And I hope ETT is the next thing to go that direction. The QEG brain mapping stuff is, I mean, that's another issue is like, you bump up against the market where it isn't educated yet. And there's like 20 competing technologies in that sector that all have different pros and cons. But they range from like snake oil to like well-intentioned but doesn't work as good as this other one to like really good.
他们不会向朋友推荐无效的东西。那太棒了。是的，祝贺这种增长。这真的很令人印象深刻。嗯，我的意思是，我们并没有那50名提供者。我们是一个五人的诊所。但我只是说我们把它带到了这里，它推动了需求，人们听说了它。这太棒了。我希望ETT是下一个朝着这个方向发展的疗法。QEEG脑图技术是，我的意思是，这是另一个问题，就像你撞上了市场，而市场还没有被教育好。在这个领域有20种相互竞争的技术，它们都有不同的优缺点。但它们的范围从像“蛇油”（骗局）到虽然出发点好但效果不如其他技术，再到真正好的技术。
But the people are all calling all of those brain maps or neurofeedback or neurostimulation. Like they're making a distinction. So it's not the time when somebody says, I don't do that. I did it and it was a waste of money. Well, you did it on a was a waste of money. Well, you did it on a $20 Brookstone machine. You know, you're just calling it the same thing as this $30,000.
但人们都在把所有这些称为脑图、神经反馈或神经刺激。他们正在做出区分。所以当有人说“我不做那个，我做过，那是浪费钱”时，现在不是时候。好吧，你做的是浪费钱。好吧，你是在一台20美元的Brookstone机器上做的。你知道，你只是把它和这台30,000美元的机器称为同一个东西。
You know, I did. Or, or the, a lot of them are protocol driven where there's not somebody interpreting the brain map. They're just like, Oh,
你知道，我做过。或者，或者，它们中的许多是协议驱动的，没有人在解读脑图。他们只是说，哦，
ADHD click. Well, you know, your ADHD looks different than mine, you know? So that I think those are, those are the market knowledge is kind of an obstacle too. Yeah. It's a learning curve, right? I feel like that happens when, especially when
多动症（ADHD），点击。好吧，你知道，你的多动症看起来和我的不一样，对吧？所以我认为这些是，市场知识也是一种障碍。是的，这是一个学习曲线，对吧？我觉得当
there's new treatments, right? There'll always be people, maybe not necessarily bad actors, but people who are going to try and like jump in and do that work without fully understanding it, you know, without being really adequately trained or, or, you know, having those supervision or mentorship that they need to really learn it well. So you get that's a that's a real deterrent in our industry, too. You know, some people are really, really focused on delivering high quality clinical care. And there's a lot of deterioration from that, too. And that causes a lot of infighting and a lot of chaos. And it's like, gosh, well, like, who's ever what patients are going to trust us if we can't we can't even have like public discourse and talk about, you know, what really works or the high quality ways to approach these interventions. So that is something that's always funny to me is you see all these like medical conspiracy theories now or conspiracy theories about therapy where they're like, oh, all the therapists go to this conference and they're you know doing to work this political end or this whatever you see all this conspiracy stuff and it's like man have you ever been to a
有新的治疗方法时，这种情况就会发生，对吧？总会有一些人，也许不一定是坏人，但他们会试图跳进去做这项工作，而没有完全理解它，你知道，没有接受过充分的培训，或者没有他们真正学好它所需的监督或指导。所以这在我们的行业中也是一个真正的威慑。你知道，有些人确实非常专注于提供高质量的临床护理。但也有很多对此的恶化。这导致了很多内斗和混乱。就像，天哪，如果连公开讨论和谈论什么真正有效，或者接近这些干预措施的高质量方式都做不到，那还有什么患者会信任我们呢？所以这对我来说总是很有趣，你现在看到所有这些像医疗阴谋论一样的东西，或者关于心理治疗的阴谋论，他们说，哦，所有的治疗师都去参加这个会议，他们正在做这个政治目的或那个什么什么，你看到所有这些阴谋论，就像伙计，你有没有去过一个
conference where people are presenting research like they are all fighting nobody like open an academic journal it's all just like clapbacks and like to to act like you you have this consistent cabal that could be motivated to get along at all i wish we were organized enough to do something that powerful. Yeah, trust me. We are not good enough at just furthering evidence-based practice, let alone being the blizzard people or whatever. Fact, yes. Well, is there anything we don't get to
人们展示研究成果的会议？他们都在争论，没有人——打开一本学术期刊，里面全是反驳。表现得好像你们有一个能为了达成一致而团结起来的阴谋集团，我真希望我们组织得足够好，能做出那么强大的事情。是的，相信我。我们甚至连推进循证实践都做得不够好，更不用说成为什么操纵者了。事实确实如此。好吧，还有什么我们没谈到
that you want to talk about with your work or perspective on everything? We touched a little bit on, I tried to touch a little bit on everything you write about. No, thank you. I feel like I could talk to people for hours, you know, especially fellow therapists, especially people who are in practice about the flaws and, and the struggles. Um, but it really does, um, fire me up to hear people who are doing things
但你想谈谈你的工作或对这一切的看法吗？我们稍微触及了一点，我试着触及了你所写的一切。不，谢谢。我觉得我可以和人们谈上几个小时，你知道，特别是同行治疗师，特别是那些在执业的人，谈论其中的缺陷和挣扎。嗯，但听到那些正在以
their own way and they're having at least some success with it, or they're enjoying it. Um, they want to stay in the field. Um, enjoying it. They want to stay in the field. I want everyone to want to stay in this field. That's, that's, you know, that's why I ride and I'm turning around and trying to shine a light on all these dark spots. It's not because I hate the industry, or I'm just a resentful, angry person, you know, it really is because I want more therapists to find and build the places where they can really stay and do the work. And it didn't work out that way for me. Maybe it could in the future. I don't know.
自己的方式做事的人，并且至少取得了一些成功，或者他们很享受这个过程，这确实让我感到振奋。嗯，他们想留在这一行。嗯，很享受。他们想留在这一行。我希望每个人都想留在这一行。这就是，你知道，这就是我写作的原因，我正在回过头来试图照亮所有这些黑暗的角落。并不是因为我讨厌这个行业，或者我只是一个怨恨、愤怒的人，你知道，这真的是因为我希望更多的治疗师能够找到并建立他们真正可以留下来并开展工作的地方。对我来说，情况并非如此。也许未来可以。我不知道。
But I want us, like, especially the people who leave or have been just really morally injured, like the people who didn't find their way to stay. I really want us to turn around and to spread light and to talk about why it didn't work and what could be different and how to keep this industry going and alive because we got a lot of passionate people who are really intuitive healers who really could make a tremendous difference in this world. So those are the things that I write about. I could talk about it forever, but it was such a pleasure to learn from you, Joel, and all the good work that you're doing. The only thing I really have to plug is my LinkedIn, where I write Brittany Lindsay on LinkedIn. And I also have a Substack where I write in longer form, which is Brittany.substack.com. Yeah, I think when I first wrote you an email,
但我希望我们，特别是那些离开或受到道德伤害的人，那些没有找到留下来方法的人，我真的希望我们能回过头来传播光明，谈谈为什么它行不通，什么可以改变，以及如何让这个行业继续存在和活跃，因为我们有很多充满激情的、真正直觉敏锐的治疗师，他们真的可以在这个世界上产生巨大的影响。所以这些就是我写的东西。我可以永远谈论它，但能向你学习真是太荣幸了，Joel，还有你所做的所有出色工作。我唯一真正需要推广的是我的LinkedIn，我在那里写作，Brittany Lindsay在LinkedIn上。我还有一个Substack，我在那里写长篇文章，网址是Brittany.substack.com。是的，我想当我第一次给你发邮件时，
I called you like Lindsay Brittany. I think I reversed them. Oh, that happens all the time. Yeah, all the time. And then some places they switch it automatically, like, you know, some online directories and things. So then doubly confusing. But yeah, thank you so much for your time. It was wonderful speaking to you. And I hope everybody comes and enjoys your writing.
我把你叫成了Lindsay Brittany。我想我把它们颠倒了。哦，那经常发生。是的，经常。而且在某些地方，它们会自动切换，比如，你知道，一些在线目录之类的。所以那就加倍困惑了。但是的，非常感谢你的时间。和你交谈真是太棒了。我希望每个人都能来欣赏你的作品。
I think one of the issues that a lot of times, you know, your stuff comes through very clearly that you have hope for the profession and that you're wanting it to improve. And a lot of times when there's more of like a whistleblower or kind of a critical analysis, people, their takeaway is that the person's just angry and they want to complain or that they're saying the thing about the system because they just feel bad or something. And there is a personality and perspective in your writing that makes it clear that these things are not good and that we need to admit the gravity of the problem and be adults and do that and not avoid those truths. But that also they are overcomable and they are things that would benefit us if we were
我认为一个问题是，很多时候，你知道，你的东西表达得很清楚，你对这个职业有希望，并且你希望它有所改善。很多时候，当有更多像举报人或某种批判性分析时，人们的结论是那个人只是生气，他们想抱怨，或者他们说关于系统的事情是因为他们感觉不好之类的。而在你的写作中有一种个性和视角，清楚地表明这些事情是不好的，我们需要承认问题的严重性，像成年人一样去做，而不是回避这些真相。但也表明它们是可以克服的，如果我们
able to do that. Thank you. Yes. A lot of the problems that we face are very fixable. And that's, I think, one of the important takeaways is that if we can be united, if we can shed light on this, if we can, you know, do what we need to do as a collective, that maybe we can incite this fixable change that we know is so needed. So I'm going to keep writing and doing what I can do to that extent and appreciate being in community with you as you do the same. Yeah, well, good luck. And thank you for your work. It's important.
能够做到这一点，它们将使我们受益。谢谢。是的。我们面临的许多问题都是可以解决的。我认为这是一个重要的结论，如果我们能团结一致，如果我们能揭露这一点，如果我们能，你知道，作为一个集体做我们需要做的事情，也许我们就能激发这种我们都知道非常需要的、可实现的改变。所以我将继续写作，尽我所能做到这一点，并感谢能和你在这个社区中交流，因为你也在做同样的事情。是的，好吧，祝你好运。谢谢你的工作。这很重要。
And if you look at, you know, people like Yalom or people who like write a ton, so much of their influence on the profession comes like almost after the heyday of their practice because you have the next generation reading the work. And then that's their, the people who are 13, 14 now,
如果你看看，你知道，像Yalom这样的人，或者那些写了很多东西的人，他们对这个职业的很大一部分影响几乎是在他们执业的全盛时期之后才产生的，因为你有下一代人在阅读这些作品。然后这就是他们的，那些现在13、14岁的人，
you know, reading your stuff may end up becoming the next generation, you know, because that they, it spoke to them. And younger people are generally a little bit better at being able to admit when the system doesn't work or just because we've done the tradition forever, maybe we should stop. I'm so excited by young people, you know, each new generation moves us forward. So I'm always excited to see what young people are You know, each new generation moves us forward. So I'm always excited to see what young people are going to do next. And if the work that, you know, we're doing, the writing that I'm doing now even plays a small part in influencing that for the better, then it will all have been worth it. Well, great. Thank you so much. And please go check out Lindsay Substack. She's got some nice stuff and we will see you soon thanks
你知道，读你的东西的人最终可能会成为下一代，你知道，因为这触动了他们。年轻人通常更善于承认系统何时不起作用，或者仅仅因为我们永远遵循传统，也许我们应该停止。我对年轻人感到非常兴奋，你知道，每一代新人都推动我们前进。所以我总是很高兴看到年轻人接下来会做什么。如果，你知道，我们正在做的工作，我现在正在写的文章，即使在推动这一进程向好的方向发展中发挥了一点点作用，那么这一切都是值得的。好吧，太棒了。非常感谢。请去看看Lindsay的Substack。她有一些很棒的内容，我们很快再见，谢谢。
joel There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
joel 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。